[Laughter]
[Music]
hello mr west
what's up what's going on man good to
see you guys seeing you too we finally
did it we're here
we made it happen we're in the building
yes sir
so what what are you doing you running
for president
uh yes what made you decide to do that
aren't you busy
enough clothing company successful
rapper
family man it was something that god put
on my heart
back in 2015 uh
a few days before the mtv awards it just
it hit me in the shower
and when i first thought of it i just
started
like laughing to myself and it
like all this like joy came over my
over my body just through my soul and
i could just i i just felt that energy i
felt that spirit so then two days later
i uh accepted the michael jackson video
vanguard awards
at the uh mtv awards and um
instead of performing you know my array
of hit songs
you know i gave uh just my perspective
on award shows
but always i knew at the end i was going
to tell people i'm running for
office i'm running for president in
2020.
and you know just to have the
it it even took heart to say it in that
context and people were just like oh
like their their minds are blown
and then i was hanging out with
different i had different friends
that were you know some people in the
music industry
some people tech elites different things
like that and
they would um really
you know they just really took it as a
joke
and they're telling me all these
millions of reasons why i couldn't run
for president i remember running into
oprah
two days or one day after that and she's
like yeah i want to be president and
you know people just you know thought
projecting putting this on you
and i i remember saying uh one of my
responses
to one of the people that one of the
naysayers was
well definitely be a billionaire by
that time uh and not that that's a
reason why someone should
become president but it's to say you
know
at that time i was uh
50 around 50 million dollars in debt
and i knew i had the confidence
that i would be able to turn that around
and
now you know just going into
i want to just give you a a yeah that
that's a clear answer
right someone i know what you're saying
i don't i don't want to go off on two of
them no it's okay
yeah what you're basically saying is you
know how to set goals you know to
achieve them
but what was oprah's rationale when she
said you don't want to be the president
like what was she saying because i
remember when people were saying that
that's our next president
remember when trump got elected you know
they showed oprah and they were saying
like there
was i believe it was like nbc tweeted it
this is our next president
like they a lot of people wanted oprah
to want to run and they felt like if
trump could win
oprah could win when i saw trump win i
was like
see you can win
you know i was um you can win if you're
coming from outside of politics i was
young when ronald reagan
was in was president i don't remember
ronald reagan was the governor of
california before he was the president
he had actually proven himself as a
politician
at least somewhat which is an idea that
people have thrown out at me
to to be governor california to be
governor of california
anyone's better than this guy
just do just go ahead start there get a
shot
open things up again man but i think and
i think
my calling is to be uh i i
believe that my calling is to be
the leader of the free world not not
i mean if if it's in god's plan that
part of my path is to be
the governor then that's fine but my
call is to be the leader of the free
world so when you say this like when you
say your calling is to be the leader of
the free world
what what does that mean to you does
that does it mean do you have a plan
that's different
than the plans that have been
implemented before does it mean that
you have ideas what kind of plan like
the plan to be the leader like what
would you do
if you were the leader of the free world
like what would be different about the
way you would handle things
like if that's your plan like what is it
about that that that is your calling
like why why would you want to do that
like what do you want to do differently
if you were the leader of the free world
well
um well there was a couple questions in
there you said why is
you know why is that your calling
there's people who will say to me
you know they'll say well music is
bigger than politics or more influential
than politics or celebrities or more
influential
and uh i thought of it like if i was a
pastor
of a hundred thousand person church but
then i was also
um uh a captain a sailor
and then we went to war and i said i'm
gonna
man this ship that has a thousand people
a thousand soldiers on it because god is
calling me
to take this position even though
i'm the pastor for you know
however big my audience is in hip-hop
uh in music or as a just an influencer
or celebrity
uh or just as a dad
and a husband in my house
the world is like
there couldn't be a better time to put a
visionary
in the in the captain's chair um
and that's not to say we we haven't had
visionaries be
uh before i'm not coming here to down
any of the other uh i'm not here to down
trump down biden uh i'm just here to
express
why um
uh why god has called me
to take this position so when you say a
visionary you think of yourself
in in terms of like as an artist as a
creator some someone who has
these thoughts that they manifest in in
terms of music and art creation design
the things that you do
that's why you you think you're
different
as a visionary yeah i
i i think that i think i'm different
from
i mean we're all different so i'm
definitely different from everybody
we're all different from each other
i mean i do bump into people that seem
to be like the same character inside of
yeah it's like i've said people before
yeah people play the same roles like
well i just met you before that you're
just like the head of this company over
here you're the same kind of person
um yeah you know i mean i manifest
i see things i'm a great leader
because i listen and i'm empathetic
and i feel the entire
earth and i feel us as a as a species
as the the human race like i do
sometimes people think of
uh utopia as almost like a negative word
that's
that's like we couldn't have that but i
do believe in
world peace like the people hit me with
the
one of the things oprah said is she said
you got to bone up on your foreign
affairs i remember this
like because it's oprah talking so i'm
going to remember a lot of what the
conversation was but that's the first
thing
she said was you know uh foreign affairs
and
foreign policies like just i think the
reason why i say
leader and that politician and not even
specifically uh
president is uh
this is the time you know when when the
constitution
was written that was an innovation now
the world is innovated
all around our political system
but we haven't innovated and simplified
our political system so i met with
um this gentleman sam uh one of the
founders of y combinator so y combinator
is a a um
is a contract that my friend the head of
dropbox used
um and that a lot of tech guys use and
it's a standardized deal
so one of the ideas i had when i was um
as i'm in this process of innovating i'm
not i'm not in
war with the music industry it's just
it's time for us to innovate
uh and we need to have contracts that
make sense with exactly how we sell
music so
you know people every vicinia and that's
like uh
every 20 years that's like the like
decade is 10
vicinia is 20. and as you see now it's
like the world is just
stopped for a second and there's an
opportunity to look
and say what are the things we need what
are the things we don't need so
i don't know if you saw when i posted my
contract i had 10 contracts
that kept on putting me inside a
labyrinth and there's things that we
don't need now
i believe that the distribution
partner that the label is like prince
would go and say
oh we don't need the distribution
partner especially if prince
was you know really alive and thriving
in this
internet era i'm the kind of person
where
i'm not trying to go and eliminate
anyone's
job so record labels are afraid of
saying okay we're going to hand over the
distribution
completely to you guys which is you know
that's a possibility
there's a way where both parties
can be happy and that these
infrastructure partners can be
of service to the influencer
to the artists like these these deals
can be
flipped in a way that they're just more
fair uh you know
a record and i'll just let let me just
go into the specific uh
place with the record labels for a
second yeah i'm talking about that this
is a confusing thing for people on the
outside
yeah so before when i told my father i
wanted to rap
he was uh very like
leery of that idea he said this
this i heard this business is terrible
and
you know he's right like people are all
seeing things that are wrong inside of
contracts
turning blind eyes to it and everyone's
responsible
everyone's a part of it you know it's
like when the me too movement
happened you know it wasn't just the
guys that were getting tagged and
you know some of the guys should have
got hit with it some guys shouldn't
you know that's not what i'm here to
talk about i'm saying that
in a way everyone's responsible
everyone's a part of the problem that's
why i really love that um
black mirror episode when you know
everyone was making comments
and anyone that even made a comment the
bees it was about these uh
you know uh mechanical bees anyone and
this is a spoiler
alert if you haven't seen this episode
but anyone who made a comment
the bees came to go get them and that's
the thing about what you put in the
universe even a thought
you know you put that thought into the
it's another thing to say something
negative and put that into the universe
it's another thing to see
someone being raped you know that's the
reason why i compare what's happening
to in the music industry to me too
because artists are raped you've heard
that term before i'm not this is not
like i'm it's not like a
new thing that i'm making up the the
contracts are made to rape
the artist and um
you know i put my like i i think about
you know this is like a thought that
right now it's like is this a
a negative thought that i'm putting into
the universe but i have to say like when
i was going on twitter i was thinking
about bruce and brandon lee
that crossed my mind to say i'm this is
sony
this is universal and i'm willing
to put the blue paint on my face
and go out and do this
because it's the right thing to do like
music like at this point it loses me
money it doesn't make
it doesn't make me money it is my my
five billion dollar
net worth and 300 million dollars of
cash that i see
a year music is like negative 4 million
for me so these contracts for me were
kind of like wang grow
and heat where this guy had everything
but he still said
wang grow messed up this this
uh this heist that we're going to do
like i look at the music industry and
that music and the love of music itself
but the music industry i look at it like
wang girl like i blame
you know the loss of my mother
partially on in the entertainment
industry the always fighting
to you know represent you know who you
are
against media entertainment in an
industry that's trying to tear down
anybody that's not uh going with the
flow i i see
you know i've got those kind of reasons
personally
uh but uh vengeance is mine said the
lord so it's not a matter of going
in for revenge that's just me as a human
being where i fall
short like i'm not a monk can you
explain what you're talking about with
bruce lee
and brandon lee like what i lost you
there okay so
bruce lee and brandon lee were both
murdered
well brandon lee died in an accident on
a movie set
yeah do you think it was a murder i felt
that's a conspiracy right the conspiracy
was that the
chinese triad killed him the same way
they killed bruce but
this the the coroner's report was that
bruce died
from uh a reaction to a medication right
yeah i mean but i think about that
anytime i go to the
go to the hospital i'm very you know i'm
mindful of that stuff you think about
like
bob marley they didn't just jfk or mlk
him there's like reports that it was
something in his toe
or he had cancer right i believe he had
a skin cancer
yeah like i went to go
uh i got a shot in my uh in my hand
because uh just from texting and stuff
my thumb was like hurt and then i told
you
so much you hurt your thumb absolutely
just texting way too much
so i post a picture
of uh the screen at the hospital
and then i was asked to take it down
by but who people just call them i
forget
exactly who asked me but it was like
they get they got to my management they
got to this and they said take that
picture down
like the hospital it was in the weirdest
place
you know so what what did they not like
about the picture
um i think it had like it might have had
some
information on it that they didn't want
to go out like an
address or something like that it's just
like but i don't want to go down
go down these rabbit holes i'm just
saying like michael jackson
not waking up one day prince not waking
up one day
bruce and brandon lee bob marley all of
these things
are have crossed my mind you know
as i'm going and saying i need to
innovate
what these contracts are not just for me
but for all artists it's not about me
getting my
masters back it's about
it's about freedom and i say on a new
song i say
if i would put myself in harm's way to
get my masters they would put their self
in harm's way
to stay the master and that's there's a
complete parallel to the way the music
industry works
and the way the world currently works
and the influence that
america has on other countries
and the way governments work uh the
influence
and the way government and the way
people in power
and control deal with
you know disaster relief deal deal with
haiti
deal with uh the bahamas
like where is the money going why aren't
things
being built and this concept of money
right i asked myself this um
uh i asked someone a week ago
like how much is america in debt and
they were like this many trillion
and then i asked my a rhetorical
question but the dumbest question i've
ever asked myself i said
well you know how much does the earth
cost
think of it think about a bad question
but but how much is the earth worth
yeah what is what is the earth what all
the things on earth
yeah and it's saying we can't buy it we
couldn't make enough money
to buy the earth right so that means we
made money
so if money is the key to
all people's happiness and we'll solve
everything and everyone's doing things
for money
let's just make more money but it's not
about making more money
it's about keeping poor people poor
and rich people rich and people keeping
people in their place
and right now we're experiencing the
fall of rome
or the titanic has now hit a glacier and
there's people who
would prefer to go down with the titanic
than to get on a lifeboat because they
don't want to get sea water on their
dress or on a nice outfit
the people are so programmed and
brainwashed
into uh classism and protectionism
that uh it's difficult
for people to embrace innovation
unless it has a tag on it
it's got a name brand connected to it
that says with this innovation you will
be better than the person
you'll be better than your next-door
neighbor you know when i made sunday
service
i i completely stopped rapping because i
didn't know how to rap
for god you know all my raps always had
like um
you know like nasty jokes on it and um
and then you know i made um
i made uh when i when i went to the
hospital i know you want to get into
this when i went to the hospital
in 2016 i wrote
uh start a church in calabasas and
as we left from 2018 going into 2019 i
said i'm not gonna let one sunday go by
without starting this church and there's
people who said it wasn't a church and
different things but
to start a ministry i'm like the little
drummer boy where i'm saying
you know this all i got to bring my my
drum i might not be
well versed in the word and but i i know
how to do make music and i know how to
put this choir together
and all things can be made good for god
so
it like quickly became the best choir of
all time because all the best singers
moved to california
and now but a lot of them grew up in the
church so it's like the opportunity
for for them to actually get paid
singing
for god because i would be funding it
and that for me was like a tithe
for me to fund sunday service and i was
four months in before i gave my life
to god like i wasn't saved it's just i
had a calling
saying just go make this church and the
whole thing
the comparison to this church to me
going and saying
okay why why am i running for president
is to be in service and that's service
to my my own ego
uh you know i feel like god says to me
like
haven't i given you enough and i gave
you an ego
that helped you overcome all these you
know roadblocks and smoke screens and
people telling you
what you can't do now you need to
realize when you're doing things for
your ego and when you're doing things
for me this is like
god the what i feel god is saying to me
uh because it really irritates me when
people say
god told me to tell you so
i'm very like mindful with this kind of
word and this i'm saying i have a
feeling that that's what god is saying
for me to be in service so
the ultimate service position is
leader of the free world to be the
president of the united states it's
sometimes you see me on twitter i'll say
i want all the smoke i want all the
problems because the problems
are the opportunities there's an
opportunity to solve things
and kurzweil uh he created the keyboard
kurzweil
uh he he has this video that marco manik
this uh director that shot 99 problems
for jay-z which is like
my favorite uh maybe like top five or
top two favorite videos of all time uh
he also did a
closer for trent rezner and i like
i just grew up on mtv in the 90s and i
love mark romantic videos but he would
share
um he'd share little bits and pieces i
remember ray curls
kurzweil talking about the ability for
us to have
a utopia but us being led by the least
noble
and the most greedy but if
someone or when someone gets in a
position
of leadership that
is in service to god and in service
to people period but
immediately the american people um
i had this joke i was saying like man no
one outside of our country should be
able to see these debates this is family
business right here this is only for
america to see we can't let anyone
outside the country see it but
to be in service so i i stepped away
already from my rap career for
a year and served
god every week sometimes twice a week
three times a week
never missed a sunday until covet
and um and this thing there were people
inside of the church stealing
doing different things trying to just
take them and god still provided a way
for us to keep that boat
afloat we never missed a we never missed
uh a service and then uh one of my
pastors pastor adam
who is uh uh uh
the way he preaches is is called
expository it's like
one to one by the word i like all
different kind of preachers but there's
some type of preachers they
they get up they have the bible in their
hand then they close the bible and then
they just talk for
uh two hours and it's and and
some do have anointing but the
expository preachers go
line for line and for me it's like i
come from entertainment
i got so much sauce i don't need no
sauce
on the word i need the word to be solid
food
that i can understand exactly what god
was saying to me through
the king james version do this you know
um
through this translation or the english
shannon version so pastor adams was
coming by
my spot uh i got this 300 acre spot in
um
calabasas uh that we had a little house
in that i was recording and i would play
this
music these chords that i love they're
almost like monk-like
um and that's going to go into something
we'll talk about later because i'm
building a modest i'm building them a
monastery that will
then be the future of uh monasteries
this like
uh full sustainable energy now
uh he says to me pastor adam says to me
when i was thinking about should i rap
or not he said my son
just said you know i wish i want to hear
yay rap do album about jesus a rap album
about jesus and it was
through the mouth of babes like this
person
i'm gonna listen to the kids bro you
know i'm gonna listen to my daughter
i'm gonna listen to kids before i listen
to
you know super programmed out adults
and especially if that adult hasn't done
something that
i am looking to do right uh so it's so
funny how people are so
like free and almost arrogant with their
advice and i'm just like
why would i listen to you you don't even
ask me for any advice i'm the most
successful person i know so
the um um
so he said my son wants to hear a rap
album from yay
and that just that was that was the
paradigm shift
for me i used that word a lot i like
that i like paradigm shift it's one of
my favorite
the and i i made this rap album
and you know for a lot of people it was
the first
album that they could play with a
certain production level
in the house with their with their with
their family
now you know you could argue if the
watch the throne production
was stronger or better than
uh jesus king production but when i go
and i like i've been working with dr dre
and some of the beats and just be like
you know
the hardest beats possible and it's
something that was very
spiritual and meditative about
the mix on jesus king that it wasn't
hitting as hard as jesus or hitting as
hard as uh
watch the throne it was like this is how
god wanted me to make this
uh make this sonic painting
and the way he wanted me to communicate
then so we did that album
and then we did the jesus's born album
which also i got that idea from pastor
adams
uh and
i mean there's people who that's the
only album they play
and it's just bringing these gospel and
i tell you like my formula for these
hymns i'm writing because i'm writing
the the songs that we're doing at uh
sunday service is basically my
book of hymns for the future gospel
university that i'm creating where
i've envisioned and will manifest
a 200 000 seat stadium
circular with a hundred thousand
gospel singers and people will go to
this university
and they will train the way you know a
russian olympic swimmer
you know a picture like they would be in
the pool six days a week at least
if not seven days but for people who
sing for the church or
you know uh you know because it's
it's it's a tide it's pro bonus all this
like people
don't practice that as much as we
practice
going to studio to rap or practice uh
playing basketball if we're in the nba
so it's making the nba sort of say
uh the coliseum for god and what that
have
have you like heard like soccer chants
and like
and just like sixty thousand persons so
i envisioned that
for god a hundred thousand people
sometimes singing in uh harmony
sometimes in
unison glory glory
oh god almighty we lift
our hands and give you
praise glory glory
oh god almighty we lift our
hands and give you praise
for picture a hundred thousand people
in unison and that feeling what that
would do for our spirits our souls it's
healing there's natural forms of healing
about
our environment um the friends
that we're around what we're wearing
what we're eating
our diet so donde is a design company
that um that uh
i formed around 10 years ago and
some of the people that worked at donda
are now have went on
to become heads of fashion houses like
uh virgil's the head of louis vuitton
and he was the head of donda
at a certain point another guy that
worked at donda is now the head of
givenchy
so this is like the the talent pool
and this donda is basically my version
of like a
cyber you know extension of my brain
like here's something that i'm thinking
of that you can't touch but we need to
we need to bring it into fruition we
need to manifest it
and we have to see how to use things of
our past
and things of our now to create our
future so it's a
organization um created to
guarantee the future of the human race
really i thought about even calling it
edna
because i see us all as superheroes and
aetna was the designer
in the incredibles which is kind of
almost really similar to donda i'm just
seeing these lineups and stuff
so um so now
our focus is food clothing shelter
communication education and
transportation so at the school that i
just created easy christian academy
you know we call nasa we call different
places about this hydroponic
vertical growing uh
garden and i remember sitting you know
the idea of the garden is
from a to z you have to be able to make
your food
right there fully sustainable right
there on your land and you know there's
a bunch of people like oh i made this
salad
right here it's like i'm not that good
enough
you still gotta go to the grocery store
for eighty percent
sixty percent of your stuff i remember
this one you know um
this one farmer we had you know he
wanted to build this
class for the kids and all this we're
going to show the kids this thing people
always make the kids version
i don't like this the kids version thing
like
kids need to understand how what if the
pandemic was
you know they lost all their parents and
it was lost the kids need to understand
early how real life works
so physics is one of the anchors of the
school that i'm
creating i remember you know i'm uh the
city is all self-sustaining so it works
off of our
four main resources earth wind
uh water and and fire and
uh 90 of it is running off of water with
like
aqueducts like the city of masada and i
was talking to this
engineer um and saying i need the whole
thing to run off of water
and he said well we're gonna have to use
solar power i said
i don't and please you know don't take
this as any offense
i don't like solar panels i feel that
they're part of still of what edison's
idea was i don't feel like they're
really in line with what nikolai tesla
really wanted to do with alternative
current i mean getting into the whole
tesla and what edison did to take tesla
down and
the fact the world would probably be
free by now if ted if tesla wasn't
basically destroyed by the media that
edison controlled in the propaganda that
edison control
so i'm i'm talking to my engineer and
saying this needs to run completely with
water and i don't want to use
uh a solar anyway and he says no i'm
saying we're going to use a mirror
and it's going to connect to a steam uh
engine and that's going to push the
water
back up and i was like after like
screaming at the guy i was like look if
i had known
physics i wouldn't have been screaming
at my engineer so if we think about
what we're learning in school to learn
physics
to learn farming i was uh i was talking
to
um a friend of mine that's a uh a rapper
and super
uh super uh god following spiritual
super smart
and i was showing her the um uh
uh some of the designs for uh the
monasteries and some of the designs for
the fully sustainable communities all
the same thing
and then it said bioengineering on it
and she said what do you
she it's like for her bioengineering has
a negative connotation
and my response was isn't like farming
and cooking
like bioengineering at the at the
simplest form like we went to
going from like grabbing apples off of a
tree to
oh we put this boom in the ground oh and
we could grow this and we could grow
this
you know we could grow this harvest
right here so it's
you know i want to just sim simplify and
round up the
the principle behind uh the donda way of
thinking
is we've got all this
information and all this you know these
science scientific um
uh exploration these things that tesla
never completed these things that
da vinci never completed and
we can look at all of these things and
see how do we create the most
primitive versions of this to create a
fully sustainable ecosystem which is
you know what covet actually helped us
to you know get closer to our families
get closer to our children
uh understand like oh wow that you know
that was mapped out for us to be
50 minutes away from our home and our
kids school to be 30 minutes away and to
put us in traffic for that amount of
time and
these cities have been designed to
promote
industry and just to make more money
they haven't been designed to promote
happiness so
we're at this paradigm shift in our
existence
you know it was when muhammad hit the
market i think that's who it was and
brought money because before it was
slave and trade
and this is something you know
dishonorable men
honor money i got this bar from dave
chappelle i'm not trying to like
steal his bar uh and you know
we as human beings this this race on
earth have like been honoring money
and you know money isn't it's not even
real you know it's not even backed by
anything i don't want to like go too
far into that but when you unprogram
yourself you see that there's
other forms of currency now like
relationships
are a more important currency than money
itself and that's what
we really saw it's like the end of the
movie that our existence would be
pre-coveted post covet and so as the
titanic
is crashing and sinking and rome is
falling
there's got to be this new civilization
like the end of tron where everything
starts to
light up and it's been under this like
dark cloud so
you know god is using me
and he has a calling you know in my life
to make the world better for
all people like people say there's bad
people there's good people no there's
there's there's people that are
possessed that have demonic ways
but we were all children at one time
they say some people no they were born
bad you got to remember like say oh
there's bad people even even the devil's
an angel
a fallen angel a lost angel like
los angeles if you think
let me but that's the city of angels let
me let me let me start
from the beginning so you you
essentially deconstruct things
so when you say in in many ways when
you're describing yourself as a
visionary this is
what i'm saying is you're looking at all
the systems that are in place whether
it's the
record industry um the contracts that
are
wrong with artists the way civilization
is set up i think visionaries too
glossy and too saucy of a title okay
whatever you're deconstructing
all of these things and you find flaws
in the systems
so all these systems whether it's the
the music industry system
whether it's the political system
whether it's the the system of
gathering food whether even a religious
system like i remember when
you started doing your sunday service
and my friend was like what is he doing
i go
he's making going to church cool again
like you don't think that's look at all
these people having a great time you've
thousands of people that are chanting
and singing along like he's not asking
for anything
i go look if anybody should be doing
something like that it's him
i go because he's making great music
everybody's having a good time
and what do you get out of that the best
thing that people ever get out of church
is sense of community a time where you
get together
and you all agree this is where you're
going to concentrate on good
you're going to concentrate on goodness
you're going to concentrate on on
and trying to find these shared values
that are going to help the community
now you're doing this in this mass form
you got the superstar
musician who's doing this in this mass
form with
thousands and thousands of people in
these gigantic areas like that's
nothing but positive so you
deconstructed the idea of
how how to do a religious service but
make it cool and now you're thinking
about deconstructing all these different
things
you're thinking about deconstructing how
how food is harvested
we make energy you're literally trying
to
deconstruct and and reimagine the idea
of civilization
yeah exactly so talk me through how this
starts with you
have you were you always religious your
whole life
yes i was and then i you know then i hit
high school
[Laughter]
so but you you know when you're a young
man and you're
you know you're a superstar musician and
you know you're living a wild life what
what was it that led you back to this
just a feeling in your life
that there was more to life there was
more to your position
there was more to you know this idea of
a calling
that you felt like you could do more
and that it it resonated with you more
to
to to produce these sunday services
and to to start thinking of of life in
this way like you can improve
things yeah god knocked me off my horse
god like
literally called me and said okay
now i need you i need you right now i
need
i mean not that god needs needs me we
need god but
he called me to serve him and
i was tired of serving the music
industry to start
tired of serving you know filling up
stadiums
uh you know when the last concert
last tour i did we had a floating stage
and uh and actually it was a hanging
stage but
it looked like it was floating and
that's just another thing that's
illusion where we need to dispel the
illusion i wouldn't even call it the
floating stage today but
the whole thing about is people used to
say how i would lose money on tours
because i would put so much into the
creative
and i and i was like wanted to prove but
prove to who you know prove to man
prove to greedy people you know that i
could make more
than anybody and that's like the
gladiator position that all
artists are put into like we're in the
middle of this coliseum
let me show you i can kill more lions
and tigers and bears and people and blah
blah
than any other gladiators that happen so
that's what i'm that's what i was doing
and then i remember talking to james
terrell and i was like
at the top of my lungs like screaming
about saving
uh saving ourselves and humanity and the
reason why me and james needed to
uh connect and then i went to uh
my show and then it's like my like this
like my head popped back and the spirit
jumped out and it felt like it was like
my mom
talking and the last thing i said was
this thing is
over and i'm saying it like i sound like
my mom like donda like that's something
she would have said
if she was in the physical form when she
sees
her son you know exhausted like i just
went through uh
uh i had this uh fashion show we had
this fashion show where we took over msg
and just broke all boundaries sold 20
000 16
000 seats and played the new album and
uh
it was you know a thousand black people
in the show
and yeah like all young thug plugging in
the iphone and
uh travis and cuddy dancing he had 50
cent there
jay-z there lamar odom the uh the first
time that people
you know saw him and walk again
uh was we walked together into the
into the stadium uh and he's camo yeezy
jacket
all head to toe and the reason why that
was so important is like when he was in
a coma
i would come by and play him the new
music
and once he was out of the coma he said
that he remembered that music when he
was in a coma and that was the album i
was
playing that day so that's the reason
why me and lamar
uh walked in together and then
the next a few months later i did a
fashion show and it started 45 minutes
late
and the media they just killed me
they lebrond me as i would say like when
lebron went to uh
to um uh miami and they said you know
who are you to have a
a choice you know like what uh one of my
other heroes tom brady he he left i
didn't see no
jerseys getting burned like when lebron
uh left so then less than a week after
that
my wife is robbed in
paris and so we we just because i'm i'm
in the middle of a tour while i'm doing
the fashion show while i'm doing this
so we cancel the tour because it's it's
very you know traumatic
and then you know
we start the tour back up and we get
back into it
and then i i just keep on saying i want
to go to japan
i just want to go to japan because japan
is like a way that people treat there
isn't like the systemic racism
embedded in every single individual
that's
inside of the place like in america uh
black white
anything there's a systemic uh white
white supremacy like when i tag you know
white supremacy or we say this it's like
the
um yes that is america that is the world
currently we've been taught that my
first superhero was
superman you know and my dad was a black
panther
but you know when disney makes black
now when you look it up you don't see my
dad
protecting his neighborhood or snatching
a mic out of somebody's hand while
they're lying
i don't know you know like father like
son right there
uh but you see this character
that's made for black people to idolize
that was designed by a white
white person and put out by a white
company so it's controlling the
narrative to say
we're going to show you harriet tubman
we're not going to show you
not turner and they do it every chance
they get
maleficent uh um
they called her her race of people the
moors
and the moors are and i just saw it
again i was just like yo
if you erase our history like most black
people we don't know
or we come we think we came from slaves
we don't know
our bloodline and we're we're given
black history month and we
take that like it's some gift to us no
it's a programming
to us racism doesn't end until we
get to a point where we stop having to
put the word black in front of it
because it's like we're we're putting
the rim a little bit lower
for ourselves like it's when i say i'm
the second
wealthiest black man in america
like why do i have to say that because
you know obviously
if we just go on wealth period of what
we call wealth like financial wealth
that score
card you know i'd be like i'm the i'm
the 78th
wealthiest man in america but we
shouldn't have to
have a special box a special month
because also what they show in black
black history month is us getting hosed
down
reminding us that we were slaves like
what if we had
remember when i cheated on you month
like remember when you first found the
found the text messages remember how
does that make you feel it makes you
feel
depleted and defeated you know it's
no matter what religion you are what we
can agree on is it is always
now but now is the shortest moment of
our life
it's gone in an instant the longest
moments of our life
are our memories and our imaginations
think about how long a kid imagines
christmas before
i mean versus how long christmas really
is and when you think back to your
christmas
are you under the table like jim carrey
and eternal sunshine with a spotless
mind like under a chair or are you a
giant
are you a king are you what blac
what what black history month has told
you you are and this is me
speaking to uh you know black people
specifically in america that
you know i know people who would you
know kill someone
in uh or have a gunner
you know in in their own hood and be
afraid to go
downtown and literally be like afraid of
white people
like the most gangster gang of gangsters
wouldn't go downtown
and that's just a programming but that
program is inside of the curriculum
it's an instant side of the media it and
it and it goes to
this whole idea of yay when people say
is jay crazy
is a a narcissistic is a
uh egomaniac is yay self-absorbed of jay
all these
no yay know who yay is i know who i am
and i'm not fin i'm not fit to
bow to uh
to an idea that you want to have of me i
am going to be the full idea that god
has of me and when i do things that are
that god don't like
i'm i'm i'm i'm being the lesser version
of me this is where i
you know in my weakness god becomes
strong
i have to be the higher me
when when people are downing me it's not
like
me fighting fire with fire me attacking
or as you say like
you know stooping to uh
stooping to that level it's like the
devil will use
you against you you become your own
uh you become your own worst enemy and i
just went on a riff right there but
the thing is these isn't that what you
do though like yeah
yeah one of the things that i when
anybody ever talks about you to me
they they they say well he's all over
the place
and i say i think that he's got a
different power source like if you look
at the way
everybody interfaces with the world if
there's a universal power most people
have like a 20 watt charger
the way i describe you i say i think
that [ __ ] got like 150 watt
charger
and these ideas are just coming at them
so you do
go on these rants that sometimes need to
be dissected into individual things
but overall you're incredibly productive
so my question is why do you
why do people think there's something
wrong with you yeah this is but
legitimately like you've been medicated
they've they've
put you away right they've brought to
you how did that happen
well i'll say these two things i think
uh very three-dimensionally i don't
think
in the black and white lines that i've
been programmed
to think in and i and i think in full
color
so when i talk i have to describe
a thought in five ways
you know we we enjoy food that has
multiple seasoning in it we enjoy music
that has multiple instruments
so when i talk it's not a rant
it's a symphony of ideas and
when you collect them you say oh these
are all these things that connect
yeah you know i i
i just tell the truth and telling the
truth
is crazy in a world full of lies
that's simply it but none of the things
you're saying are crazy another things
you said are crazy
it's fascinating the way you think
because
i can see that you're thinking in all
these different layers and you're
looking at things from all these
different perspectives
and they all come together out of your
mouth in like a tornado of ideas
now if someone wants to just have a
conversation with you back and forth i
could see whether you go this guy's
crazy just doesn't stop he's ranting
but what i'm seeing is just you're a
very thorough thinker
you're thinking at things independently
but you're thinking of things in a
massive perspective
now who convinced you that that's bad is
it have you
always been this way or were you
less is it was it less manageable before
did you have issues with it before
yeah i believe before i
found christ and gave my life to god
i would try to lean on my own
understanding and that's
the universe is
like a black hole of information what do
you mean by your own understanding
meaning when people ask einstein said
you're the smartest person what would
you like to know
he his einstein's response was i'd like
to understand the mind of god
meaning meaning god is all-knowing and
we can only know or see and for me as a
visionary
we can only know or see what god allows
us to see and what he
feels we're ready to see and understand
to to maximize what our mass laws
hierarchy and e chart is you know what
sets our dopa means what sets our
serotonins off
what makes us feel good basically like
you know we we did a good deed
and it's like it was somehow where you
know you know just doing a beat
for a famous per or just doing a beat
for
um a local dope rapper
really meant a lot to me when i was 14
years old
doing a beat for just anyone famous that
had a major
record deal was a lot to me at age 19.
me being able to you know put out my own
music and put my
own i was a lot to me at age 24 meaning
as i grow god sets
new stages in the game of life for me
that you get your
satisfaction like maslow's hierarchy of
need is like
our satisfaction chart what makes us
feel whole
and uh accomplished as a as a
as a human being so as i go through
these different levels there's times
where
i would use confidence when i knew what
i was doing
and i would use arrogance when i didn't
know what i was doing but i'd rather use
arrogance than to let someone
diminish my idea of myself because that
is what keeps us going hope actually
keeps us alive
anybody you ask most people is like do
you want tomorrow to come and they say
yes they have they have hope for it but
i went from having
confidence and arrogance to having faith
and faith
is the opposite of fear and that created
this
fearless approach that i have and that's
what
made now has made me the fearless leader
that i am that i've like crystallized
into
the leader that my mom always knew i
would be
when kids followed me in preschool the
leader
that people saw when we changed the
sound of music the leader
when we changed uh the the sneaker
industry the leader
and what we're doing with uh with
farming and with with shelters
when i was building you know the
homeless shelters uh
a couple years ago and visiting parks
and and then going to skip row and
understanding the uh uh the
dynamics and empathizing with what
actual
mental health issues are not someone
you know telling their truth or being
exhausted
and then being labeled as such like
i am so that's what you felt happened to
you like you were
absolutely truth and you were exhausted
and they labeled you as mentally
unhealthy
yes absolutely am i saying this right
that what happened with you
is you feel like maybe
or you probably feel like that having
this
higher calling and recognizing this
higher power
was the the glue that kept your thoughts
together they kept your mind straight
and it kept you on a righteous path
so instead of being scattered with all
these crazy thoughts and being exhausted
and
being labeled manic right like we talked
before
and you were saying that they had you on
medication but the medication [ __ ]
with your creativity
it [ __ ] with all kinds of things or it
blocked my ability to channel
what god wanted me to do but we're all
we're all on medication right now did
you use
toothpaste with fluoride today it blocks
your pineal gland and they put
children on it and we put we put our
kids on it you know we
it's inside the the deodorants that we
use is all these things to
create like a disconnect to god to serve
that
it's like are you serving man are you
serving
the the one and only master but what did
they tell you
when when they said that they were going
to put you on medication what do they
put you on
and what did they tell you one of my
favorite things that they did is they
put me on this medication
that made me uh gain a lot of weight and
i said i'm not gonna take this
and they said okay we got a medication
you could take but you won't gain weight
and this shows you they were trying to
kill a superhero
slowly trying to kill genius trying to
make me not feel like i could run for
president make me not feel like i can go
uh be born in atlanta grow up on the
south side of chicago
go into music go and win all these
grammys
change the sound of music and the look
of stage performances
all that and then still end up in 53
million dollars in debt what music
industry has people going to the exact
debt of the house that they think
they're gonna buy
after the tour is over and it's and it's
it's strategized there's criminals
all over everyone's almost
accounts in the music industry it's not
a safe place it's a
it's a treacherous place so filled with
money soon as things are filled with
money they're filled with people that
are trying to take advantage of other
people
it's filled with money bees come to
honey exactly exactly
so they put they put you on this ship
because you were exhausted
what did they put you on um
um you know i'm i can i can research
i'm actually forgetting the exact
medication
that they had um but what did it do uh
you
the main thing that it did is
it destroyed my confidence it made me
this shell of who i really am
it like grayed over my eyes
it it it made me
it made the mustang that buck anymore
hmm
they sedated you yes yeah and
they what was the the thought process
behind it when you talked to a doctor
about this
what did they tell you was wrong with
you
uh they they told me i was bipolar
and i remember going on tmz and saying
you know slavery is a choice and they
medicated
me for saying that for having that
opinion
and saying it out loud but as i put
those contracts up i'm saying
this is a choice as i you know
you didn't mean people being abducted
and brought into slavery and
put into chains was a choice what you
were talking about is
people making decisions that would
enslave them financially
and enslave their life yeah it was taken
out of context
and it was taken in the least charitable
way
and they decided to try to say look at
crazy kanye look at this [ __ ] he's
saying
and then they medicate you yes
and the media has always taken anything
out of context that isn't a part of
the overall narrative yeah that
because there's you know like hollywood
and media
has controlled so much of the narrative
and then
he had silicon valley and that's what's
so beautiful about
one of my heroes steve jobs because
there wouldn't be
a silicon valley or the silicon valley
wouldn't be
what it is today if steve jobs didn't
make
information accessible like this which
is still
a bit controlled but it feels like
twitter is the
the safest fleet freest uh
mass platform to communicate on
and you know it's like they mess with
jack because of that you know you know
well it's it's still censored there's a
lot of issues now but i think that's
internal i think that's people that are
working there that are woke that want to
stop people from saying certain things
and there's a lot of struggles with that
today
and i it's unfortunate because i i do
agree that it's an
unbelievable way to get ideas out there
yeah so
but it's also it's a new thing and it's
mismanaged by the people that use it
often
they don't know what they're doing or
why they're doing it every version of
anything that man
has made will be flawed sure and it has
to go through a bunch of different
steps of evolution it has to it has to
evolve and change
so why did you agree to let them do this
to you why did you agree to let them
medicate you
because if that is that look i'm crazy
for sure
but if someone came to me and go hey
we're going to put you on some
medication that medication is going to
calm you down i'd be like
everything i do is because i'm not calm
everything that i've ever done that's
made me successful
is because i have more energy it's
because i i have a wildness
like i'm not calming that down like i
know how to calm myself down
i can self-medicate with exercise and
meditation and
marijuana and a bunch of different
things but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
take some medication that removes
anything that's unique with you
and all these wild ideas that come to
your head like very few people could
string together these thoughts the way
you're
describing them today if somebody asked
me if there's anything wrong with him
he's [ __ ] he's filled with awesome
like what's what's wrong with that if
you can keep that together what you just
did the way you just described
reimagining civilization reimagining
church reimagining
the food supplies there's nothing bad
about that
this is all very interesting and very
good like i would never say that's bad
but are you this way all the time or is
there good
versions of kanye and versions of kanye
where you don't feel like you have a
grip on
these thoughts you know what i love is
there was
uh some perspectives that people
showed about what a true
manic episode really looks like after i
was in south carolina
and this one guy was talking about his
mom being in an episode and kidnapping
his brother
and you know like proper extreme
cases you know i
cried and was gut
wrenched like at the
i don't even like to say out loud what i
s
what i said on south carolina but the
idea
of you know i'm just
trying to word it in a way that's really
safe and covers my family
um
people saw this clip of me crying some
people didn't know
what i was crying about but i was crying
about
that there was a a possible chance
you know i'm just i'm looking at a way
to say this
that there was a chance that
you know that we didn't make that kim
and i didn't make the family we have
today
that's much that's my most like uh
family friendly you know way to word
that
and just the idea of it just tears me up
inside that i was a part of a culture
that promotes this kind of thing like
one of the uh major statistics
on the subject of life is
um that the greatest
advocates for um
the a the a word is
are men from ages 31 to 37
and that's how old i was and
i felt like i was too busy my dad felt
like
he was too busy for me and
we have a culture of that and
they have a child rebel soldiers
that were in africa that would be doped
up
and psyched out and made to kill their
parents
were well in our culture we're doped up
and psyched out
and made to kill our children you know
we have to decouple the conversation of
uh planned parenthood and
woman's choice now so of course i'm
christian so i'm
pro-life um
and when i go into office i'm not
changing laws because i realize we live
in an
imperfect world in an imperfect society
what i will be presenting is a plan a
and we've already started to work on
plan a to change the
connotation of orphanages to change the
connotation of foster care
and not just change the connotation you
know verbally
but to create places that are to the
level of like the amman geary and disney
world how to had a kid
you know what is this like and we have
so much land
that this can be created and then spread
across
the world to orphanages in africa and in
china and just
um uh across the globe to
to create these environments that when
there's expecting families moms and
fathers
that they feel like there's a place even
if
they don't feel well off enough to bring
another life into this world that
there's a place to go there's a plan a
because plan b and planned parenthood
were planned
by a eugenics that set out and said
out loud i'm doing this to
kill the black race and to create
population control
you know if we what are you saying plan
b mean the pill meaning the
the morning-after pill you know what let
me planned parenthood let me let me let
me decouple those things let me
let me talk about planned parenthood
okay
there's the last figure i saw is there
were 210
000 deaths due to covet
in america and everywhere you go you see
someone with a mask on
with a the a word
a culture i'll say it one time with
abortion culture
there are 1 000
black children aborted
a day daily we are in genocide
we so more black children
have died in the past
since february than people have died
of covet and everyone wears a mask
so it's a matter of where are we turning
a blind's eye to
like the media can control a lot of
times it has to control what we care
about
i even heard somebody say at one point
this is the actual sentence i heard
someone say puerto rico so played out
meaning there was a time where people
were caring about it and now the media
says don't care about it but these
people
it still hasn't been solved the the
hurricane's still
hit the earthquakes still hidden people
are still suffering from that
and no one has really gone to fix it and
when that 11 billion
goes to haiti and it doesn't get to the
people
you know the daily mail post a
a swimsuit pick or something and uh
deters our energy to what we have to do
collectively to
to to to help our brothers and sisters
you know i look at
society as as one body
i want to just go into this rift because
my thoughts are like
these clouds and mario brothers and i'll
jump to this and i'll see another one
i'll jump to another and say oh yes i
jump to another
i need to express this uh this story
i believe that you know
love will heal all and
we have to look at i believe i believe
that world peace is possible
and i believe it's us looking
at each other as a moment in time
time is love you love the things you put
time into that's where i'm in time is
love like because this is like
uh this intangible thing this thing you
can't grab you can't just grab time in
your hand you can't grab love in your
hand but
but we feel both of these things are
real for us to love one another just as
simple as that like
love will heal the world this is
what it's gonna take to heal the world
but we have a competitive spirit we like
having a bad guy we like having a
competitor
so what we need to do is change the bad
guy change the competitor
make the competitor be the roman era the
roman civilization
make the uh competitive be the
egyptian kingdom and say we are the
first society
we're the first civilization that
ever became civil because we are still
just as much in the dark ages
as medieval times or as game of thrones
you know level uh black mirror
level i i know i went past future other
dimension for a second
but we kill each other we kill each
other on
social media we kill each other in high
schools
like in the way with that we talk to
each other we
we physically kill each other in our own
neighborhoods and
outside of neighborhoods you know this
planet
when we when we keep turning a blind's
eye
to our brothers and our sisters and our
family which is
us as a whole as all of humanity then
of course it's going to get to the point
where
there's you know homeless sleeping under
you know a um a bridge in calabasas
because we ignored the homeless person
sleeping in front of the gucci store
how do you how does just look at that
visual
it's a homeless person sleeping in front
of the gucci store
we have builders we have people who know
how to make
communities we have people who know how
to cook and how to make food
and how to um
how to bring this food people are
fighting over land and not really
realizing
that we're not uh we're not maximizing
our resources and our existence
we've got genius level
scientists we've got people who rogue uh
you know people who have uh broken out
of the chains like elon like imagine if
elon was
working at gm on the third floor
somewhere
you know we wouldn't have electric cars
we wouldn't have
that new porsche hybrid we wouldn't have
uh
uh what what's happening with you know
hyperloop imagine if
the guy that uh you know started airbnb
uh uh was shut down or the guys who
started uber
were shut down all of these people who
break away
and then create the new society and the
next frontier where we're going people
like i've said
like it feels to me like mit is a place
that has to be funded by people who want
to take the smartest people on the
planet
and make them work on the smallest
things that won't change
anything and i've talked to people from
mit and i could
look at these brill like this brilliant
person i was talking from mit
and he was he was afraid everything was
fear everything was about
his his girlfriend's pregnant and you
know we just got a house
and i don't want to do anything to
change this and i and this is like
one of the most brilliant people on the
planet but if you mix
brilliance with bravery that we can
ignite something even this conversation
alone can ignite the people that are
going to change the world because
there's people who have been anointed
you can't teach
the brilliance and the anointings
there's people who hit the game of life
and they've got something that they're
going to do no matter what school they
go to
they know they just know how to do it
they knew how to do it before they got
here
and they were going to do it and these
people just need to
see what it looks like to overcome
the smoke screens of public humiliation
of bankruptcy i was in debt
uh the fear loss i lost my mom or the
fear of death
you know what other fears uh are there
there's a lot of fears but
the thing is when you remove like even
in the schools you remove prayer you
remove god you remove
the fear of god you create the
possibility of the fear
of everything else but watch this
if you instill the fear of god
you eliminate the fear of anything else
and it's not that i am
fearless i am
definitely literally definitely shaking
and in so much fear of my father
i fear god and i don't fear nothing else
there's some power to that right like it
just has a mental management tool
there's some real power to that because
so many people are afraid
of every single little aspect of life
bills and debt and love and
relationships and if you have a higher
power
and this is one of the things that i've
always wanted to make what's the main
word that you use even for fear this is
the main disease
that that people use in politics it's
the main
fear is it but it's a main word it's the
disease
attacking the world because it it it
destroys your it changes your posture
it changes your idea it's worry yeah
worry yeah anxiety that's right that's
what it is stress
like it can kill you you can't be free
you can't be free to take chances
to be worried about stuff like an honest
yeah
so to be able to anchor and eliminate
worry
and say this i am walking in a righteous
path
and i don't have to worry about anything
i don't have to worry about going to
jail i have to worry about being killed
i don't have to worry about bankruptcy i
don't have to worry about
um you know uh humiliation
you know because this comes this is
where smart alec prayers can get you
i used to have this really smart outlet
prayer i said god
deliver me from pain
and then he took my mom
so it's hard to hurt that much
ever again and create it
almost like a character like deadpool
i'm like deadpool
for god like there's no
noise there's no human noise that can
and
you know someone tried to like there was
there was a friend of mine that did like
a really bad
move where he tried to say
i was using this this this lawyer and i
was about to
work with him and he said the lawyer
said he wouldn't work with you until you
get my contract done
and i was just like having do you not
know me
at all i'll be the type to cut off my if
my hands are like this i'll cut off my
own hand i come back in the room they'd
be like yo what you doing here i thought
we tied you up i'm
like
and then i go just make like a luke
skywalker
you know you know han and this is one
thing i want to say like
and it's about to make me mad right here
the first time you see me get mad in the
interview
they said that george lucas's prequels
are
worse than the corporate made disney
star wars
i'll get mad at that too like that's
[ __ ] ridiculous
revenge of the sif we saw how darth
vader was made
yeah like i watched that like 10 times
doing covet
like don't jump anakin i got the high
ground those early movies were pure
they were pure no no i'm saying
even the prequels are better than
anything
that and i'm sorry disney star wars
design team i know you're gonna like put
my
face up in the you know office and be
like forget
no man this is george this is his baby
that thing was set in his heart to show
us his children the hero's journey you
know
and these these like how can we running
back and replay like even
at disney you know there's there's
people you know at a
pixar that have left people have left
you know where
um uh they call
i've forgot the exact title but saying
like every time is a new idea
they call it like an unproven idea so
they'll get to toy story
800 000 and frozen trillion
before there's a new concept uh
to take a chance on yeah to take a
chance yeah and we've been we've been
programmed like
when you see the you know the homes the
style of homes that i've been developing
they're far closer to the way the galaxy
looks the way water looks the way our
makeup in our body
feels uh we've been uh we've been put
into these boxes and that was you know
due to money they do the construction
that we have to be in these
these boxes and we've been stuck in a
loop
like on uh westworld and something i
feel like tandy newton on westworld
where
she had to use the people that enslaved
her that trapped her
to make it to make it out you know the
uh and it's funny when i
like the box and when i'm talking about
farming i had a point about farming that
i didn't finish earlier
i hired this guy to do the a to z
concept i made it plain as day
make it so everything we cook in the
kitchen at the school
we plant it here and they would just do
it
to 70 percent they'd do it to
60 percent earlier when i had that point
i went to this whole riff about
children needing to learn physics and
children needing to learn how to really
do things and not having this separated
thing
like we are programmed to
lock ourselves in a box and what's
amazing right now is
the opportunity and the platform that we
have that the world is hurting
for everyone for those that are in power
for those that are inside the program
even those that are
in power are still a part of
the program and you know i
read this uh this tweet that someone
said i finished watching
netflix what's next and
that's so true that
we can't even program enough to satisfy
ourselves
the program is done forrest gump has
stopped running and just
turned around it's like all of this
thing is a setup the
the the the concerts that musicians go
to where we don't
you know we're not thinking about the
fact that we're not getting the lion's
share of our masters because we're
making the money on tour and then tour
has
girls and tour has the the the the arena
singing your song and i need you right
now
did you do good champ you know like uh
with floyd mayweather
um is is such a hero of mine and so
excellent because he is a a champion
right
but then also he wasn't afraid to say
i do my deals i make my money and what i
like is
you know he didn't let the the older
system
tell him how to spend his money or how
to show his money
it was up to him because he's the he's
his own king
you know god is the king of us all but
he's his own king
and a lot of times in america we haven't
seen
we haven't seen kings we haven't seen
the the the
the royal blood in our bone marrow
and the way it comes through now we can
show it
in and rap and the way we put our chains
on the way we dress we can show them the
way we play ball and things like that
but it's
another frontier to being
to being a king well there's also
something where you feel diminished
in the fact that you know that your
money is being stolen
by people that don't deserve it so if
you have some record executives if you
have some people that you know
have looped you into a [ __ ] up deal
and they're making millions while you're
making thousands
that [ __ ] with your head yeah it just
does
it makes you worry makes you stress
gives you exactly anxiety did he touch
you it could drive you crazy yeah it
could drive you crazy
yeah yeah so i still don't understand
how they talked you into medication man
i wish i knew you better
back then because uh i would have just
had you exercise
i would idea i would say so what
whatever he's doing
you can't do like you have to understand
that
different people have different amounts
of energy
they have you you have this ability
to to have these like really
all-encompassing thoughts where you have
these
long trains of ideas and thoughts in
your head and you're implementing them
this is all good this is this is a
powerful thing
i don't think it's a negative thing at
all i mean some of it comes to
you know i'm dealing with issues that
are not
just you know black and racial issues
i'm dealing with
uh maverick you know innovator issues
yeah i'm dealing with you know just as
many
uh you know issues where there's walls
of
you know invisible walls and invisible
chains as
you know michael jackson dealt with as a
black musician or
urban musician where he had to go and um
urban he came with thriller he's like
let me go get this person who directed
which is the eastwick
to i'm gonna get a movie director and he
changed
you know uh movies forever i'm dealing
with some um
some walls that you know people have
done to hold back
uh agents of change throughout history
you know
it's like the movie is here like this
part
you know us talking right now may be a
scene from my life's movie
uh like tesla was
you know a a white guy that
was a ladies man and he would be going
to all the like
fancy events and everything and like he
stopped having sex at age
40. yeah and said you know i'm going to
focus on it and
and i mean he died he died penniless
at the end you know i'm not gonna say
like he turned evil but he's trying to
sell a bomb
and he had all these like answers
uh that would change the construct of
society and like my best example is like
kodak
is there in a place where they can
barely pull it together now but they
invented
the digital camera and they didn't bring
it to market
because um because
um they had all this film to sell
well one of the things that's really you
know that's a challenge for me is
you know i've i designed
this thing this we call it the foam
runner and we built a factory for it
and cody and you can make these uh in 25
minutes
and what i'm saying about design i was
talking to one of the
just awesome designers that we just uh
uh got over yeezy we got like this
amazing crew we got guys that nike sued
us for and one of these guys i was
trying to hire him for two years
he had to he had an encounter he had to
go surf
for a year and now he's in and when he
like
you know does is um is a cad drawings
it's almost like one shot one kill you
know sometimes you design stuff you got
to do it like
five eight times like his first one is
so close
to being ready to go to market because
he sketches in a certain kind of way
and for the longest we said you know
let's um
uh i've been saying i want to get rid of
laces and
we still have shoes we sell with laces
because it's a popular shoe and people
love this shoe and it it hurts me i feel
like steve jobs trying to like remove
buttons off the side of the next
apple and one of the things that's
interesting about this if you look at
most sneakers if you look at you guys
sneakers right now
you have a tongue you know and it it
goes this direction
this is one of the innovations about
this is one reason why this is one of
the most
important sneaker designs is this goes
this way because it's ergonomic
and i remember putting it on and being
uncomfortable
with wearing it because i'm so used to
like the way like a jordan or something
fits with my jeans and i remember
talking to kobe and him talking about
having to make sneakers that fit with
jeans and that was a big thing because
you know that's what we grow up we go
you know coconut jeans and jordans or
something like that so
um this also i feel that
just the process when i design i become
like a three-year-old i have to go to my
gut i have to forget everything i know
and really focus in to what i feel like
some straight jedi
yoda or like you know if i could grab
that water bottle like
like wouldn't it have been cool if i
just did it right now i should have had
a magnet on there that you feel like
he'd be like yo this dude's a wizard
um so
so so for me you know i i'm gonna make
this shoe
be twenty dollars and you know
money isn't real so that means the world
should be eventually free
so i'm gonna manifest the world being
free my dad
he lives in a dr and he says you know
anything
that you put in the ground grows so why
do people
still go hungry and i like that in
theory but i was like man farming is
really hard though man i think
you know i might go hungry if i have
someone to farm this food
it's like but you know back in the days
we
we had that skill set now we're losing
these skill sets that actually we can
sustain off of
uh so with this uh and i
i love giving you guys my riffs i'm like
a human version
of instagram when you look at instagram
you look at
you know you're looking like a hundred
images a day
uh well i've got millions of images
in my mind and the majority of them
haven't been realized yet you know
there's some
images that are from my memory but i got
this whole
the future that's in my mind that has to
be brought
so this is you know you talk about hype
culture and shoes being sold
on the you know the resale market and
yeezy
lives in that place but i i you know
i don't like the idea i don't love the
idea
that some of the reason why people buy
it is just
uh for hype culture or
you ain't got this or i got this
colorway and you don't have it that type
of mentality
i mean it's i'm an essentialist i'm a
i'm a minimalist
and like i i i have to i will
bring the the fully a to z
our existence version to existence like
victor gruen
designed the shopping centers but he
designed full utopian communities
and people were like oh we're just cool
with the shopping center that's all we
want
and these ideas that he had never got
brought into fruition a little bit like
disney kind of based epcot center on
like
on victor gruen but these
this next frontier of these communities
and villages of happiness
are way closer to a kenyan village
than it is to like a gated community uh
village but one of the things about your
this aversion to hype culture one of the
good things about the hype culture is
if people get into your products they're
going to get into you and they're going
to get into your ideas
and all these ideas that you have will
become a part of their thought process
they'll start thinking about it
they go hey he's got some great points
if people really get into your [ __ ]
they're also really going to get into
your ideas i think it's one of the
things that make people uncomfortable
about you
is you have the courage to have all
these bold ideas
and to implement them and to do all
these different things
that bothers people and there's a lot of
people that don't have that kind of
courage
and they are straddled down by anxiety
and they see a guy like you and they
like try to find flaws
they try to find things that are wrong
with it instead of looking at the
positive aspects of it
they'll only concentrate on the negative
aspects of it i don't think i don't see
it that way i've never saw it that way
i look you look at that guy [ __ ] do
anything there's people like tesla
and there's people who you know there's
a person who
killed animals with tesla cords to make
people not like tesla yeah the personal
citizen
yeah person who made the electric chair
be made with the tesla courts
for so people wouldn't like tesla tesla
still has inventions that haven't been
brought
to our society that would have brought
more simplicity and happiness to our
society
like the westinghouse ability to
transmit electricity through the air
which is fascinating i don't know if
that would have worked in today's
world with cell phones and all the
different electronics and even
you know modern air travel i don't know
i don't know what it
would have worked but things would have
been different people
are over designing into industries where
they see they can make some money as
opposed to stepping back and saying
how do we look at the entire earth
as an opportunity to free
everyone and create happiness for
for everyone so like only a b there's
only a billion people on the internet
you never think about that there's seven
to eight billion people on the on earth
but then there's only a billion people
that are influenced
and that are on the internet we feel
like the internet
is everything it's only like 15 you know
18 of human beings
but in order to make
for our civilization for us to survive
we have to make more human beings we
have
we have family we have we have to have
food we have to have shelter
that we don't have to have the internet
we don't have to have
music we don't have to have you know
that's a conversation
i mean i mean i mean it enhances life
yeah it enhances the quality of life
is better but look at the music look
look at look at what the information
where we're we're uh we're putting in it
like i feel bad
when i hear uh rap songs i feel bad even
the stuff that
you know i just recently put out i was
like you know how you listen to lames
they the imitation man like why is
that's just
i don't like that message because we're
all the imitation of our parents and
imitation of this invitation and then
imitation of adam and eve you know we're
and
we're uh we're all the next versions
there should be the v2 v3 v4
like you know michelangelo and da vinci
had the same teacher
you know there's times where you know my
like
uh people work with me or just say like
my mentees or whatever will go out
and they'll do something uh that i
wanted to do and then i'm i'm torn
because as a man
you know i'm i'm i'm jealous and i'm
proud
at the same time and it's like a
father-son relationship because
sometimes when the when the sun goes out
and is more successful at things
the father wants to say that's a good
job but every time the son does
something that's a good job it reminds
the father of his failures
yes so it's just i mean it's a it's a
it's a it's a strong dynamic that that's
where i have to lean on god
to not be like you know this uh
this like uh prick
that's jealous of you know people who
are innovating or taking
you know the the goal line because we
got to realize we're in a relay race of
humanity
at a certain point whoever you know what
what what the inventors in the in the
past did is now handed over to the
inventors today
they're handed over to the next vendors
well the good thing about the walls and
the perception and all that is
this like smaller barrier to entry
allows there to be you know a walt
disney
and a steve jobs and a henry ford so
what i'm doing right now
there's a there's a there's a real
barrier to entry to doing
constructing homes and communities and
farms like you can't
you can't just do it like how you can
just you know
it's hard for someone to go from i'm not
saying it can't happen
i'm just saying that it's difficult for
someone to go from
you know programming and putting their
music out on the internet today
to what it was that michael jackson had
to do that very entry was so hard for
him
that i mean since he this guy was the
leader of the jackson five when he was
five
like his entire life led up and this is
what he focused on
and it made and it was all focused on
that
so it made the great michael jackson now
i want to do this comparison of disney
uh steve
and uh uh henry ford and what yeezy is
it's really hard to make houses it's a
it's like a corrupt
uh industry also you got contra how many
times have you started on a house and uh
contractors like start over charging for
stuff and the budget ends up being
twice the amount and it's twice as long
look
if you had a relationship that's why
relationships are
a better currency than uh than um
than money if you had a relationship
with the contractors
if you were part of their family your
house would be done
quick i feel like it's a practical joke
on rich people
how long houses take to build
i was in the airport and there was a
first class line that was super slow
and there was a coach area with like
eight openings and there was no one
in it and then i hopped out and this
other gentleman hopped out with me and
went through that line and we went
through
but the rich people with the hermes
belts didn't want to lose their position
so bad that they would rather wait in
the first class line
than to have the time back and go
through that now this gentleman
is a surgeon that works on people's
hearts through their
feet so it's like that kind of engineer
serger doctor mentality he's like yeah i
got money because
this this is what i'm doing but i'm here
to serve and i have a mentality that i'm
not better
than the person that's in coach which is
the reason why we were the only two that
went through
uh that how do you segue off of this
when i just go into this like how do you
even find
a question what are you thinking over
there right now
there's no goodness yeah yeah there's no
reason to
worry about it yeah you you have this
thought do you have a rigid
process that you organize your day with
like how do you
you you seem to have so many different
thoughts and so many different things
going on simultaneously
like how do you how do you organize your
day
do you have like ritual do you have yes
i
uh drive my children to school
i drive my kids to school and
i stay at school with them all day and
you know i'm in the kitchen
like uh working with
the top chefs on the planet to create
this
you know these healthy menus and i'm
working with the farmer so
the school that i'm at is also
um it's like this new
i don't wanna no disrespect to nasa i
was gonna say new nasa but
um of humanity that we're anchoring it
around uh our children so that's what my
day consists of but then i
also uh in the past couple months
have been going to atlanta for two days
a week or three days a week
uh because i'm building this uh 120
000 uh oh i'm not supposed to say that
i'm building
we're building a sound stage but um and
but it was funny because i go back and
forth
on content should i work in content
should i work in tech i have all these
like website ideas and
tech ideas and i sometimes i was like
i'll say i'm cursed by tech
like i'm not you know i don't have any
curses um
or god has lets me break the curses and
break the chains i rather say
i i don't know if content is my calling
like messaging like let me show you what
a school of the future
looks like let me show you a monasteries
of the future let me show you the farms
of the future look like but we're 20
years past the future
like it's in 2020 like we're supposed to
be in the future by 2000
so it's my job to pull the future into
now and that's something i struggle with
when i talk about the different things
that i'm doing
getting into the idea of doing like
content for netflix or content for hulu
and like
what that content because i believe
we're in the movie i believe we're in
the game
we're in like grand theft auto it's just
too many things that
align and we're not we can terraform
what we can do is be like if your grand
theft auto character just started
redesigning the world
himself like painting his own his own
world we have this opportunity
to make life as fun as these second
lives
but if you look at how politics
just general unhappiness misery control
the speed that contractors go the
farmers that wouldn't finish the farm
the way we are with each other is why
people feel like look
everyone's going to go into like this
ready player one
second life and i believe that our first
life
can be just as a imaginative
uh and it will be so that's my and i
have a bunch of friends that work in the
gaming
industry and i have friends that work in
the content industry and i'm saying
i'm anchoring on real life to make real
life as
awesome as games to make real life as
awesome as uh movies
so did i answer the question of my
schedule
every day yeah but i mean you so you
just basically
go on what you feel like working on you
you basically
just start your day you you do your
stuff with your kids
and then whatever these ideas you have
you just
nourish them you just encourage them you
just
you just feed whatever thoughts are in
your head
well yeah but what i was expressing
on that on that last um symphony i gave
you was uh
this uh was um that i do have this
challenge that's where i'm designing i'm
just
i'm actually designing what i'm doing
with my time saying
[Music]
should i be even taking a meeting like
when i take a meeting
this i know if it's a good or bad
meeting if someone's talking to me and i
just get sleepy
i know that that's not what i should do
but if someone's talking i'm
you know energized i like saying the
word energize over the word excited
because this is what they do to this is
what they do to
all of us they get us excited excited
and anxiety they kind of go together
like someone can say hey i
got you a new car um and it's across the
street
you get so excited you run across the
street get hit by a car trying to run to
your new
but if you're energized about having the
car perhaps you look both ways see i
played this dictionary game with the
like this uh um this small webster
pocket dictionary
and we'll go to a page and say go to
page with the word help on it
and we say highlight all the words you
think are positive and then we talk
about afterwards
why do you think that's positive so the
word help is like
it's like a uh it's like a bad leg on a
table
you think you could stand on it but if
you stand right there that table could
flip over
the fourth definition in the word help
is
to ignore and it actually makes sense
you know oh like if you have a meeting
right here's the answer when you know
the meeting didn't go do good
uh after it didn't go well the person
says it then oh how can i help that
means they don't want to do nothing
let me just give you a phone number
right you know the word
is to ensure and then there's a lot of
words that end with ure
that are very powerful future sure
pure endure and um
that that goes into like the rhyme
because i'm literally trying to figure
out the video game
at all times and see where these things
uh parallel i know this can get into
like a riff where people like
okay yeah you're losing what you're
saying right now but um
but look at that look at the dictionary
look at these words i have friends uh
that
uh english is their second or third or
eighth language and they say that
english is the hardest
language to learn because there's so
many words to
uh to that mean the same thing it it
like it tears me to my core that
my daughter has to learn two the
difference between two t-o-o
and t-o i wanna just be like
just draw the number two like just make
it like sometimes i don't know
when you know the difference i'm like a
terrible speller
and i believe that there's like
curriculums that are that are european
curriculums that don't even apply to
our genes you know who we are as a
people like african descent people
we don't even talk like that like this
is a skill set but i'm still
talking white basically like you'll see
like a black pastor
you know give this amazing like sermon
or like marry someone i was at a wedding
and this guy
they said wow he speaks so well well
what do you mean well he speaks
super white like yeah that's what the
definition of well
right right it's just sounds that you
use and to communicate ideas
right yeah well it's funny i bumped it
to a friend of mine
um i actually met williams i said uh
givenchy i wasn't expecting to see
i wasn't expecting i mean expecting
to see him i wasn't expecting to see him
and
we're at the mercer lobby and he caught
me off guard
and i was like i didn't use words
when when i when i when i saw him i like
almost communicated in a different
language like a language like joy or
happiness only 30 percent of our
communication
is is verbal that's why the masks just
really throw me off because
i can't tell what someone
is thinking and feeling because a lot of
times half the time people don't say
what they're thinking and feeling
and i have to decode with the mask
i can only you know hear what they're
saying
that's the problem with social media too
right yes things are black and white and
things being
taken out of context i mean that's the
reason why people
like you know love the show that they're
like oh we got the yay
joe rogan we can hear him go into all of
these riffs
yeah and we can feel him you could see
you know how i'm looking you can see my
energy and the way i'm saying it too
yeah so and
you see people sitting down having an
actual conversation
a real conversation yeah and and a
conversation where
anybody that comes on this show you
don't have like this
like sometimes with reporters they have
like
people that are media they have like a
complex you don't have a complex you're
like yo
let's first off to get this straight
like if i like
i could whip your ass i'm joe rogan i'm
a professional fighter now let's start
the conversation
which i think is another reason like
with nick cannon he's like
man i married mariah carey i did all
these and both of these interviews have
been very positive because people aren't
carrying
something already like some form of chip
on their shoulder where they gotta like
atta every sentence sometimes i talk to
reporters it's like
they're saying the thing they wanted to
say to this guy in high school that they
never got to
complete the conversation and they're
taking it out
on me i'm like
yeah i think there's a lot of people
that have conversations with people and
they want to
create a viral moment too that it's not
just a conversation
they they have an agenda it's it's
almost like you were talking about the
disney star wars movies
that then it's not a work of art it's
it's a formula
like two plus two is four let's put
those together we'll make some money
instead of the original star wars which
was the hero's journey which was like a
joseph campbell book
it's just like there was a beauty and a
purity to it
it's a it's an expression like someone
comes up with an idea and they bring it
to fruition
and then you get to watch and you're
like wow it moves you
the new movies don't move you and it was
a crew
of of um of leaders of thought leaders
that like i was a
is it brian de palma that told george to
put the words at the beginning because
it's like you really
i all i've been feeling like is like
when i talk up to this point i just been
making thx
you know and then the toys from star
wars have not come out first which would
be like
you know like the yeezys or something
like that and now some making the whole
star wars
in real life like backwards like the
product came first kind of like disney
like disney
he was mickey mouse became super popular
before he was able to get all of his
imagineers uh imagineers in
i want to point out you know when people
talk about
being you know self-absorbed or the
center of your own universe
um what's the main character in star
wars name
luke skywalker who created star wars
george lucas oh
but did he write it but listen to that
last name yeah
that's yeah george luke
yes yeah he's the main character in star
wars
he gets this esther
and it was awesome yeah there's there's
something about
uh things that are pure right versus
things that are
attempting to recreate something that
people are going to like
there's there's a difference and it's
it's in music as well right like
your your music resonates with people
because it's obviously coming from your
mind
whereas some people are creating songs
that they think are going to be hits
they're creating top 40 it's coming from
my heart
and my gut but when it's the most pure
it's coming from god and i'm being used
as a channel it's like when
tanya harden hit the the triple flip
you know she had all that skill and then
at some point
it's not called a trip i'm about to say
trippy triple lindy like is rajiv
or rodney dangerfield or something but
it's like
there's these moments where we do things
that are
seem like superhero level and i think
that's what m knight
shalamon was laying out for us
with unbreakable uh
glass and what was the other one with
the guy with the multiple personalities
just like he's got three of these
films that are like showing us hey
you're
superheroes you can believe it the
greatest disabler
of our of of our abilities our greatest
our greatest kryptonite is doubt right
you know
fear yeah doubt like why did i um
you know um
like going to why did i register so late
uh to run for president covet
i like i remember like i i had
uh i had the virus and i was sitting
you know quarantined in my house and my
cousin
text me about being prepared to run for
president
and i just completely pull like put it
off to the side
because i was like shivering and you
know having the shakes and taking hot
showers and eating soup and
you know just sleeping i don't think it
was that bad
i think it was a mild case um
and it just threw off i mean it threw
everyone off it threw everybody's plans
off
and then you know it was just this
calling on my heart and i remember
talking to like really like
elitist um uh
you know writers you know i was trying
to avoid saying white supremacists but
like
elite like the the the liberal elites
are like you know so
boy who you gonna vote on you know like
who are you to run for
office and why would you sign up for
office
you know uh if you if you can't even get
on ballots
that's people are saying that to me and
i could get on the ballot
it's like there's black mothers that go
into hospital
and the doctor will tell them that
there's something wrong with their child
to get them
to this is happening uh to this date
and then when people say you know are
you are you a pawn
like for the republicans
the reason why i think that people are
asking me that is because the
because the democrats do create black
pawns
they do have celebrities that they'll
sit down and meet with and say you're
going to be an advocate
for the democratic party and you know
everyone's like
you know and i'm not trying to take any
sides of like republicans or democrats
i'm just saying why where
why were people so much thinking that i
was like
uh a form of uh a pawn and then the idea
that you know liberals would say like
the funny thing is liberals i think uh
and i'm i'm
i don't know if i could classify myself
as liberal but
i'm i'm definitely kind of liberal elite
i wrote my beautiful dark twisted
fantasy like i've had some of the best
writing so that would put me in that
class so to say but i'm also just a
purist like i see a kenyan home and be
like that's beautiful right there i'm
not like
i gotta have the so the
one of the most racist things that
liberals who pride themselves on not
being racist
have said to me is like uh you're gonna
split the black vote
and that makes it seem like black people
can't make decisions for ourselves and
that
don't know white people know me like i'm
like only
the liberal they literally make it
saying like only
black people will vote for me right
think about that statement the
the nuance of institutionalized
racism and this would be like somebody
from the art world
you know i mean they just have a place
where
no one has really been able to embrace
the idea
of blacks not being in a block
and staying in one place right or blacks
having a devote democrat
yeah or blacks have an opinion like us
not being on boards or
us being like handlers for other black
people meaning like
if we work at a label or we work at a
big corporation
it's our job to go talk to the other
black people
you know to calm other black people down
but we're working for
you know uh universal or vivendi
or uh whatever the
organizations were you know i was
thinking about buying my masters and i
realized that that was too small of a
thought
i'm gonna buy universal
they're only a 33 billion organization
i'm one of the greatest product
producers
that ever existed i'm i'm and i'm a
child
i'm 43 years old i was 53 million
dollars in debt
uh uh you know four years ago
and now it's proven that i'm the new
michael jordan
of products i went to adidas and
we were a 15 billion organization
losing 2 billion before kova hit our
market cap was 68 billion
i went to the gap and are partnered with
the gap
and our stock jumped 45
in two hours the organization made two
billion dollars
and two out in two hours and now
we've doubled we i mean the gap was uh
mark cap was lower than yeezy it was
like three billion dollars
when when when i first got there now
it's like seven
eight billion dollars and we haven't
even released the product yet
but what i loved i you know i sat there
and i did the deal without getting on
the board
and i looked at my cousin and i and i i
didn't want to sign the deal without
being on the board and i looked at him
and said i'm doing this for you
meaning like this is part of a relay
race it would just be a given
that if someone of color
was to your position my position of
influence
would be on the board but michael jordan
had to break down walls
and michael jackson had to break down
walls for
us to break down the next walls and the
next walls are
the boardroom because you know what the
boardroom is it's an opinion
see people are fine for us to play
basketball and
you know rap and make clothes
but the the society is set up is not
really used to refine with us actually
having an opinion
and i can understand why because what is
our opinion based on
if we grew up thinking we were slaves
if our opinion isn't based on hey my dad
taught me how to run this company
you know my dad is smarter than me and
everything he wanted to do
black people thought he was crazy and he
had to do it with
white people who thought he was
incompetent because he was black
and the way these companies and the way
uh the music industry the way managers
and the way society generally looks at
uh black people is
the way like a misogynistic man looks at
a hot lady
what can you give me what can you do for
me
no one a misogynistic man not gonna look
at a hot lady and say
can you run my company so
you know this idea of me you know and i
i i got like
you know i'm building my factories i've
just simplified the design
and i was working with a guy that uh you
know
um that's helping me to you know build
some of the factories it was an older
white gentleman
and he just matter-of-factly says we're
sitting at his house
uh in malibu it's a nice day he's just
matter of fact
he says adidas will never put you on the
board
and i'm like this this wall
has to come down like how could you not
have the guy
that has the best idea so one of the
great things with universal one of the
approaches that we have is
you know universal when jimmy iveen and
dr dre
sold beats by dre uh universal had a
chance to buy in or do different things
they sold it for three billion dollars
that was half of the value
of universal at that time of six billion
due to the internet which
the music industry was afraid of in 2000
universal now i think is a
worth 33 bill 35 billion dollars
um and now they have another steve jobs
you know howard hughes henry iv disney
elon
kind of character within their midst
but they're so concerned about
the control of the idea of
artists because they're using me as like
this artist that has attracted other
artists
it also i use them i got famous i made
some money i got to tour
you know i became this superstar so we
use each other now this is just an
adjustment that needs to be made in the
relationship
and i can make and i will make products
that
will make more money than universal is
worth
but it's not about the money as i said
earlier it's about the fact
that even though my net worth is five
billion dollars
and i'm one of the most famous most
influential god-fearing
christians on the planet the
i still have to go to this man or this
organization
and ask him for something and that is
what it's about you can have a company
right
when you go and do your companies don't
think because you got the most ownership
that you actually have the control if
you don't have the information
and the knowledge of how the
distribution works
and you're not having that conversation
you don't have the control so what i did
in my organization
with universal with gap and with adidas
i told my lawyers my managers everything
no one can communicate
with these organizations except for me
you can give me advice
but they gotta talk to the boss which is
me
and right there you start to get the
information flow
i guess who's my cfo who me
so that means i do have the time i do
10 to 15 transactions
what i do is i pay because i had open
credit cards i had
checks you know i had people flying in
and out
i had a consultant agreements like
people who weren't on the salary but
they were consultants
i had you know uh
people paying for flights hotels cars
food netflix like
everything just running the account just
even right now
i cancel all my credit cards except for
one credit card this is like the oprah
winfrey moment where she's like
man when i started spending cash i was
like i really realized
you know how much i was spending and i
signed all my own checks and the thing
that happens in the music industry
uh is and just a lot of industries like
people tell you that someone needs to do
something for you
and it's like look this siri do
everything for you know you can do
it's possible and it's just when you ask
me how do i delegate my time
it's important for me to delegate my
time if i made
210 million dollars last year
and yeah i have a lot of maverick ideas
i'm working on cities and homeless
shelters and farms and i'm reinvesting
myself so a lot of
mavericks will you know spend their
money on their ideas and they'll invest
in what they see the future is and i
ended up with a net worth of 10 million
i remember
you know a few a month ago people were
like
you can't show your taxes because people
won't understand that you're a
billionaire
if they see that you only netted 10
million last year
and after the gap deal happened my net
worth
went from 3.3 billion
to 5 billion and i had been asking the
people around me
to run the story and they were going to
run it with bloomberg they never ran it
i was not afraid of people looking at me
like i was not a billionaire
and i said be honest show my taxes show
every
everything and then the reports came
back oh you're worth 5 billion
it came from me just being honest when i
want to say something about the gap deal
also and specifically the name the gap
in my
and my journey with that like at age 16
i worked at the gap i always saw the gap
as like being
the apple of apparel i always had this
comparison with siege i always felt like
i was the steve jobs
of the gap it was something about how
clean it was and what mickey drexler had
done
all these commercials and like you know
at age 16
i was uh working at the gap and i got
fired for stealing and i was actually
stealing khakis i was stealing khakis
from my friend
funny thing look i stole khakis for my
friend when i started doing music at age
19 18
i went and bought a chain i came home
one day
didn't see where the chain was come to
find out my friend was smoking crack and
it stole my
chain so the guy i was stealing for end
up stealing
from me um but um it's khakis i was
stealing some gap khakis i wanted those
khakis that bad
um so then 27 years later
you know i give my life to god
and i start doing sunday service one of
the things that
i had to do for sunday service or i got
to do that was fun for me to do
was to design the wardrobe for sunday
service and we would redesign
t-shirts and it says in the bible that
jesus wore a seamless garment so we
started
building t-shirts where the scene was
only here or only
two seams on the shirt or moving it
around and what the neck was
and i made t-shirt after t-shirt after
t-shirt and christianity we said we
stand in the gap
so watch this this opportunity is
presented
and i always had clothes that were kind
of chill like they could be at the gap
they were not overly fashionable
and god said you you you stood in the
gap
and i'm gonna have you stand in the gap
for real and i'm gonna give you favor
and increase and i know per some person
i know somebody where all that design
and t-shirts will come in handy
i literally was designing t-shirts for
sunday service
like david working out in the field
tending to the field
you know when goliath came uh they
wanted one of his brothers and the
warriors to
to go up against goliath and his father
chose
david and david said i don't need all
this armor
i just need these three smooth stones i
just need you know this is how i got to
see they didn't know david
had had to fight a lion and had to fight
a a bear
so god by him tending to the fill
in humility and in service to god and
honor to his family
he was able to have the skill set to
take down
goliath we hit the street you know it's
a term that i had to learn
wall street we hit the street like you
never ever saw it before
i used to be in san fran asking people
to invest in me nobody invested me
when i went to a wedding in san fran
with all these billionaires and
investors
angel investors you should have seen
people's faces they were like you
jumped from the three-point line you ran
a stock
by 45 percent you see think about this
you're gonna split the black vote
you can't vote for that you you're only
a rapper you're only it's like
all these things that diminish me yeah
and now it's like
deadpool like i came back as like a
superhero
and i won't let that be the kryptonite i
won't let my own ego
be my kryptonite i won't let other
people's opinions
be my kryptonite i won't let these
labels that people put on me
be my kryptonite and a lot of times i
don't like to watch these interviews
back until about you know three four
five years later because
i'm always you know i'm visiting the now
i'm existing in the future and visiting
the now
when i'm speaking to you and they make a
lot more sense
in the future because i can tell you but
he can show you
god can show you so a lot of stuff i'm
telling you and some people are
following me some people are believing
in it
and some people are just doubting it
because they want to put this label oh
he's crazy or
it's just a black guy saying it or it's
just a rapper
it's just a it's just an entertainer
it's just whatever it is
so i can say the most wild ideas out
loud it's like veronica corningstone
wanting to be an
anchor person and i remember she said so
ron i told you
i wanted to be a he said yes i heard you
i wrote it down
veronica corningston had a very funny
joke tonight and every time i talk
it's literally like veronica cornerstone
having a very funny joke tonight like
when i said i was gonna run for
president
that was like okay go ahead would you
like to interject
do you have thoughts and ideas also that
you'd like to have be a part of your
interview well you went from
you went from people mad at you that you
split in the back black vote
all the way to the gap and all the way
to veronica i made it
but then i brought it back yes you did
to the vote to run it for you
brought it back from to people doubting
you and people putting limitations on
you
people are tuning in this podcast to go
on the journey with us yeah
listen they do or they don't it's up to
them yeah but do you know
the beautiful thing is you're not
listening to these people these people
that are trying to
put these labels on you and tell you
what to do and
you're not saddled down by fear you're
not settled down by
doubt you're you're willing to take
these chances if you did become
president what would you do that was
different
i mean pretty much everything i was just
looking at the suits last night i was
like yo
[Laughter]
what would you redesign i don't wear
white anymore they had a white shirt you
know they had
like a i just
um i would i would
redesign this i i will and it's not a
wood right it's not a if
it's not a if it's just when right um
we got to start with the budget i feel
like
you know the fact that i went from being
in debt
to uh to
uh being i don't even like the way it
sounds the multi-billion because we
think about steve jobs money is like the
least
of what's awesome about him and the
money is just a tool like it's like
nails like i got the most names you feel
like it's scored on the scoreboard
though
it proves it proves not just value but
it proves
effectiveness yeah and it's like you're
crazy to your right so it proves in some
way that
a lot of the things i said that were
crazy i was actually right about yeah
looking at that budget and i think that
that's part of god's like
training like mr miyagi paint defense
you know karate kid
daniel son i on that i gave like the
full description of the
uh of the analogy just in case uh people
didn't um
what do you think you would do though if
they come to you with talks about
foreign policy people love talking about
foreign policy that's the number one uh
question yeah but when i talk about the
budget
you know this paint the fence the fact
that i had to
you know that i have to understand
300 million dollars of cash a year that
you don't get trained for that that's
like astronaut training that i have to
understand
how to have multiple industries that i
have to understand
how to build and
house and provide
you know i i provide people with health
care and i could
i had this idea of doing a zero employee
org where
i i put everything on my partners on
universal on the gap
on adidas but i believe this is amazing
training for me as a
a black person there's people who who
have been
raised to respect a penny but as a black
person
i've been raised to look down at a penny
but the people who really
hold their money respect every penny
they respect the money
and it's interesting i had an argument
with uh one of my managers because i
made my own travel ban
in my organization because you know i
did
when i did sunday service a month and a
half ago it was 25 flights coming in and
people i didn't know
because there's criminals in my
organization trying to kill bob marley
not to jfk or mlk me but deplete my
resources
so i created this travel explain that
what do you mean by that what i mean by
criminals in your organization like what
do you mean meaning
there's people that okay i fired this
one cfo
about three months ago and up to a week
ago he still had an open credit card
because i i'm gonna dig lower and dick
lower and go to it it's like always like
is this the new person that's in charge
of your money it's like no i'm the new
person
that's in charge of your money that's in
charge of my money rather
so so that's why you became your cfo
that's why i became and it's
it's the best and it's it clears my
thoughts and it really helps me
with design it helps me as i'm designing
uh uh designing uh what i'm doing at the
gap it helps me
when i'm how i'm designing the
curriculum it helps me
in the way i'm designing the kitchen the
way i'm delegating the way i'm working
the way i'm
and being a better leader being a better
uh being a better listener wait a second
but there was some question you had i
had i was answering
and i gave it all before you went to
foreign policies i went to the
the budget well i said it's like
danielson painting the fence
the fact that i've had to really look at
and understand
that kind of money and this god-given
anointing
being a producer being a head of
industry to be
a fearing and god and a servant of god
and a producer and head of industry at
the same time
is literally like the perfect
combination
for a president and to be honest i'm
literally like every now and then
america has to get america deserves the
world deserves
a leader that they can 100 percent
trust that whatever i'm saying
to you with the information that i have
in front of me
i 100 believe that
like when i talked to the uh when i was
with the president of haiti
and he gave us an island me and shervin
pisivar
that was an early angel investor at uber
and is working on the uh
the virgin hyperloop right now a really
great friend of mine he saved me
he's had me avoid deals where i was
gonna give up a percentage of my company
for a third of the value and different
things like that
so uh we go to haiti and the president
uh uh gives us this island to develop
uh to make a city of the future and also
we're gonna have the farmers and the
people who live there
take a percentage i mean take ownership
of the land that they have right now so
when it raises in value
they all eat off of uh what the idea is
but he said that um
the way that he has done uh business
with our president
is so straightforward
i believe that i know that me as
president would be the best thing that
ever happened for america's
foreign policy i've traveled more than
any president
already and i bring people together i
put rivals
on songs together to create masterpieces
i go and i empathize when i meet with
leaders
in africa when i meet with leaders in
um i didn't really have a good uh next
thing i wanted to sound good and like
naming
leaders and i wanted to sound
[Laughter]
see honestly so when i when i meet with
when i meet with leaders
i'm not trying to go in there and see
how they can use my internet i'm not
trying to go in there and buy up their
land
and develop it and buy it up for cheap
you know we're we're going to share
information
you know we're uh you know we have
a idea we just had of a dual citizenship
for
americans with african uh dissent uh
that the ability to create
environments and communities completely
can change
the way uh
people act you know if people are hungry
they're gonna act a certain way
people have food they're gonna act a
certain way people are away from their
friends and family they're gonna act a
certain way they're gonna need to
they're at a college town they need to
stop by this you know frat party and you
know
drink and do the but when they're uh
you know but you got to go here so then
you could go there and like society is
all about
dismantling the family i see things
being more like a kibbutz or
you know where the family can be as
close and when the grandparents can be
next to the children and um you know
these
ideas i have about um
how communities uh ca should be
are worldwide simplified ideas and that
they're not based on
industry even though i understand
industry they're based on serving god
and serving families and that's
something that
everyone across the globe no matter what
country in the world whatever
continental world
all of the moms and dads have something
in common they want the world to be
better for their children
we all want the world to be better for
the children
and we can show ways that we are not at
odds think about the world is a
giant piano but we're playing off-key
so for a producer to synthesize those
ideas
and not say okay we're gonna shut i
spent time in china
i spent a year in china when i was uh in
fifth grade i used to speak
chinese like new york like i
i don't know a lot of yeah my mom was an
english
professor they had an exchange program
where a chinese student could
come to america and she could go to
which was there was
like chinese at that time couldn't come
to america
as uh as easily so
you know there's america's greatest
export is influence and
culture china actually has like
imitation paris imitation they probably
got imitation calabasas at this
they probably do at this point you know
the the artists define culture that's
what makes there's the artist
that made the design the statue of
liberty
there's an artist that designed the
eiffel tower
this is the reason why i donated 100
million dollars to james terrell's
rodent crater uh uh
project when i went to this is like the
eighth
wonder of the world but i saw spaces
that we can exist in that would be
helpful
for our health our well-being these are
healthier
places for us to be we need to be like
almost like turalyon's like our our life
is like a shakespearean
uh like shakespeare has written 30
percent of uh
our language that we use like i say like
he must have been a really nice person
like
davinci used to walk away from people
when he would talk to people and that's
but that's the reason why it's the da
vinci code and at the da vinci
life because he never was able to get it
across to the
to the to the level to affect us for
generations to come
these people love art but they want to
put art in the box
we need to surround ourselves with the
artist because the artists
are the the most connected
the most truthful and their dinosaur
never got killed
somehow the people who have figured out
how to make a
real a living off of art is what do you
mean by the dinosaur never got killed
meaning art class
would be considered to be fun like every
kid loves to draw
yeah right but some people got to grow
up and like the artists
right in some way don't have to yes like
this separate we're all children we're
all if you're if you're alive
you're a child we're all children in
god's eyes and we're all young
people like jesus is a old person like
he's oh
like you know like adam is old
you know if you're alive you're you're
young
and we're like children and there's all
these things these sharp edges these
corners these anxieties these fears
these things put in our
our food our diet our diet of what we
consume right here
that turn us old and make us brittle and
make us
uh put that fear on our kids don't you
put that evil on me ricky bobby they put
that
they put that we put these evils on our
children we put racism
on our children we put fear on our
children and the the children are
fearless the children
it's it's funny it's like claudio
sylvestre one of our lead architects i
worked with since
uh age 24 he built this home in my
oracle with john with john
paulson and he has like this golf
course which it's in the acoustics are
incredible
but it's this part where you can walk
along that's 20 feet high
and i said you know would you you know
what about the kids what
you know you have a balcony you have a
banister or something and he looked at
me and said
they're smarter than we think
wow and meaning like if we were never
taught
the missing banister theory that
we could all tightrope walk the missing
banister theory i wrote it in my book
thank you and you're welcome that i
wrote with my friend sakaya that's
actually here right now that's uh
uh that you were talking to earlier is
look you could walk down a straight line
without worrying about anything uh but
you take that exact straight line and
put it 20 story high
20 stories high you know i'm going with
it yeah and you remove the balconies
you're going to be so concerned about
the idea of falling that it will make
you fall yep
and that's where the superpower is in
removing the fear
yes that's a beautiful thing to say
right there
and it's also probably the first sound
biteable thing that i've said the entire
all right let me talk to you about so
we're serious here so let's talk about
like real
presidential issues let's talk about
like here's
here's some things that just when we
talk about this country
here's some things that are that mean a
lot to me one student debt
i think it's crazy i think it's crazy
that we take children
when they're 17 18 years old we send
them way to college
we make them literally hundreds of
thousands of dollars in debt and then we
ask them to go out into the world
and try to manage this money and and try
to get a job that's going to pay them a
fraction of what they owe
for their education i think it's crazy i
think we should figure out a way to
absolve student debt
i think we should figure out a way to
make education
at the very least far less expensive
than it is now
this is this is a big issue for people
absolutely i'm i'm completely confident
that i will figure out how to get
america out of debt
that i have the ability once i see
everything i never make the wrong
decision
when i'm giving all the information
that's my that's my skill set anything i
go into
producing rap homes
clothing anything once i'm given the
right information
i apply my taste and i have the best
taste
on the planet i mean quincy jones
there's a couple people that's like
okay crazy don't taste might be better
than mine but if quincy could you
imagine quincy jones
as a president i could yeah
or uh walt disney uh steve jobs like
maybe some of these personalities are a
little volatile yeah yeah but that's how
he gets things done
yeah like for america to be as
warming and inviting as as as disney
world
there used to be you know this dream of
you know people still have this dream of
coming to them
they're coming to america like it's
the america that i grew up even with
like when ronald reagan
was in office it's like he was hanging
out with michael jackson
and you know it's like it felt america
plus the way the media showed things
like the american dream
was alive and well and
even at the same time in in the ghetto
it was a living hell and we were being
you know given you know bricks were put
on the street
uh bricks are pulled on the street doing
the riots now bricks are putting on the
street
in eighties a different kind of brick
and there were guns placed
and the fathers were being taken out of
the hood and this is all this so don't
let me say like
everything was perfect doing that um
doing that era but the perception right
now perception is more important than
it's
ever than it's ever been like what we
show you know it's just i mean it's
outright
it's it's just uh i don't even wanna i
don't wanna i don't know i don't wanna
dwell on it let's keep going into what
you're saying about the debt because
also i don't have
like if you ask me about covet i can
only give you my perspective as a
civilian
i don't i'm not talking to these the
same people
you know and i also empower the geniuses
i was talking to my man uh fred and my
boy anthony
about crypto and bitcoin you know the
uh yesterday just to be prepped for this
conversation and not about the specifics
of alternate currencies which is like ac
which is like tesla which is like but
the uh this that my mind just goes on
these like riffs right here
but uh jack dorsey decentralized twitter
two months before it really hit because
he was talking to
the bitcoin guys and these are guys that
really have a perspective on what
the true liberation of america and
humanity will be
these guys a lot of the the specifically
these guys but a lot of the tech guys
were able to use the new highways the
new information highways
and create the next frontier of our
existence
while the powers of our
uh political system are still
anchoring on electoral college
which was based around slavery about the
idea
of slaves being three-fifths of man and
get this
it wasn't even created by pro slaves
three-fifths of man was created by the
anti-slaves in the north
as a compromise and that basically
explains
the existence of black people in america
to to this
day the people that were on our side
supposedly said we were three-fifths of
men
the people that were on our side the
people
on our side thought of us as
three-fifths of man meaning like
yeah come work for us but you know
you're three fifths of men sitting you
have electoral college
and gerrymandering happening to this
date where if you have
uh uh latinos uh
uh blacks other minorities they're
redrawing
the lines to affect the vote
to this day that does not relate to the
information highway that we live in
today that allow
all these you know tech guys to become
multi-billionaires and lead
uh and and and and
lead free thought or allow you know as
best as we could a version of free
thought
i i know i gave you a symphony but you
see how all this
really connects we're sticking you know
why don't we just keep
why don't we why don't we put the white
wigs back on they still wear the white
wigs down uh
yeah england they still wear it you know
that's the whole thing just because
you know someone's not you know wearing
uh uh uh a kkk
uh uniform or a white wig doesn't mean
that they aren't holding on
to the very core of the
the country being uh you know uh based
on
and built off of slavery so when
everyone's saying
vote you know that's the reason why my
mercy is vote kanye because like
vote for who look man if you ain't gonna
say who you voting on out loud don't
even wear the vote t-shirt that's so
random
right that's so rare and we always know
voters like democrat and stuff because
there's nobody is that trump that's like
wears a vote t-shirt isn't that funny
but it's such a go ahead if you do say
that yeah you say
vote is mostly vote democrat like and if
you have an american flag
mostly you're voting trump like these
are these are
realities that we've sort of accepted
and it's subs it's all this subliminal
stuff that's that's based on like fear
and control even like this like this
look at this
the whole this is the three-fifths of
man thing right okay
the democrats were willing to take the
chance of not
winning as long as the conglomerate
could be completely
in control of
as completely in control you know what
i'm saying that bernie
yeah bernie would have won he would have
won this is something
i wore a trumpet i'm saying like bernie
is a superhero
yeah you know and he would be the
perfect
the perfect and the perfect person to be
the opposite of what trump represents
yeah he's an anti-capitalist he's a is a
guy who's a social democrat
and you and but you know the problem
they couldn't control bernie
because you can't you can't control him
he's been so consistent in his whole
life
so so what i'm saying is they literally
kicked if this doesn't say something
it's like
they kicked the superhero you know
saying they they
well they wanted control it's the same
thing they did with tulsi gabbard but
bernie was interesting because he's this
democratic socialist because he's got
these ideas that are scary to capitalism
you know it's funny because i i created
the birthday party which
on the on the next selection what's
going to happen is i mean you guys got
300 million viewers you know after this
it'll probably be 900 million because
you know i run a stock up you know
you just do a little bit of bill cosby
in that neck
the uh no doubt jello pudding
exactly exactly so uh
so this is a long rant but i really
would like to talk to you about specific
things
okay i mean it was a beautiful long
symphony but there's a there's a cap on
it there's a pop
we don't we don't we don't we don't want
to catch up
but there's a possibility that i could
um it's actually technically possible
for me to win
now which would be the best option for
america
i would uh i'm i'm on uh 12 ballots
and in 17 states that you could write me
in on so if people
got up people that never voted uh got up
registered voted for me they'd have to
take it
take it to the house because
i would you know i could possibly win
now i'm definitely 100 winning in 2024
and with that thought i was like okay i
got the birthday party but i was
thinking
maybe there's a possibility i would be
they said that wouldn't happen i was
thinking i would you know
possibly be the democrat you know i
don't think they would ever let you in
like that
but i don't know maybe who knows what
happens after this joe biden kamala
harris thing
who knows he knows what they think you
know some you i would be the first
i'm
i'm trying i'm not trying to i'm one of
the
first
super famous public black
free will uh
servants of christ uh since
modern media has come to pass meaning
when i when i when i talk i'm not
talking for a conglomerate
i'm talking for myself in service to god
that's it that's it like i'm not
you know i'll cover my people cover my
family
but there's not some big plan or like
some practice script thing where it says
you go in and you you say this
you you do this we we've got we want to
keep
uh selling kodak film so we want to stop
you know you from bringing out the
digital camera we want to keep you know
selling this
raising the price of gas so we're not
going to look to
how to like safely harness nuclear power
or to do electric power
okay go ahead ask another question i
really just
i quite love the sound of my own voice
as you can see apparently uh
it's okay so it's this microphone we
started it sounds great
so we started with student debt and we
got we got on this long symphony
yeah um have you given thought into the
idea of free education
and particularly here's a big one for me
as well free health care
i think if we think of ourselves as a
country and
our country as a community we're all a
bunch of people
that are together if we're going to take
care of things like the fire department
if we're going to take care of things
like the police department education
we've got to take care of health care we
got we got to make it so that people get
sick they don't go bankrupt
we got to make it so that no one has to
worry about being taken
care of and i i and i don't mean
to eliminate the ability for someone to
hire a private specialist for surgery or
anything like that
i'm not i'm not saying that but i'm
saying at the very least we have to
cover
base medical concerns for the population
it's just
it's an a giant part of what what it is
to be a person
is to to worry about your your body
being broken to worry about being sick
to worry about what this is going to
cost your family financially and how it
could ruin people
this is a i mean this is a huge issue in
our country is
medical health so have you thought about
that
absolutely i i hear you and i feel you
and i feel what people are going through
i think that
there is a it's not just
how we treat people there's preventative
measures yes
that can help us from getting sick our
our diet our
our locations are our the our our jobs
there's a lot of that
that affects us and puts us in those uh
situation transportation you know like
as you go into like autonomous uh
vehicles and tram systems like just kind
of
you know trains that are like uh
floating malls or floating
uh starbucks or something like movement
like designing
our world to be the world of the future
will
uh will help us with health that's the
preventative message and then as far as
uh being more inventive in the way we um
we connect uh holistic uh
medicine with modern medicine i believe
in both
medicines i believe in god i believe in
god and nature i believe
in uh science
and physics and you know it's like
the first simplest form of
bioengineering uh
i think is farming and to
be able to have like i talk about the
the guys at mit the greatest scientists
in the world there's people who
are that are like the elons
of the the medical field but perhaps
they're sitting there on the on on the
floors like
serving on the front line fighting covet
uh where you know they didn't have the
opportunity to
create paypal and become a billionaire
and go to the
next idea or when they present it and
want people to invest
in these inventions that they have they
haven't had the voice of the platform
to bring this invention there's cures to
things like one of the things is the
silver bullet
like what what i went through with the
medication when they gave me the
medication
that made me fat but then they said okay
we have one
that doesn't we we all know what a
silver bullet is in medication right
so it's the um it's a medication that
goes and just kills exactly what it's
supposed to kill
but for capitalism
that's not the best medication to
actually cure people
capitalists want to keep people they
want to treat them they want to treat
they want to keep you sick
because that's how you you keep making
money to have a guy
like for me when i say i put my life on
the line i think about abraham lincoln i
think about
jfk to go in and sit and say
you know the whole thing is no everyone
is going to be more prosperous i think
is the word
not specifically are you going to 5x
your money everyone's like
trying to get no it's about prosperity
and to be able to
really have real conversations with
the lead heads of like big pharm
and real conversations with the heads of
uh of of uh holistic
and and natural healing to put these
people in a room together people aren't
even having
they're mad at each other they're afraid
of each other uh
i i i donated to a christian school in
cody
and um i also
went by and saw this other amazing
school
in uh in cody where they have
uh autistic children and kids with
special needs in the same
classrooms as uh
other as regular kids and
i just saw this juxtaposition and the
head of that that
school is uh a christian but
it's a state school so there's no prayer
in the school and then the other school
is fully christian
but it's not a state school so they
don't have money in the school
and i wanted to have dinner with
uh both of the principals come to find
out
the principal and these guys they talk
maybe at a
softball game or something the principal
house is one block walking distance
the principle of one schools houses one
block walking distance from the school
or the other
principal that we're this close
right now we have the solutions but we
all have our backs to each other
we need to face each other and like how
we're facing each other right now
and have these conversations the
solutions for
utopia are in front of us but what's
holding us back
fear people are sitting on their money
really they're sitting under their money
i know i'm gonna give you a thing okay
that's it next one
did you get did you get my perspective
of the real the way i would approach
you would bring people together to
communicate and try to figure out a
better strategy for health care
yeah i mean and and in reality some
financial realities that have to be
in london when you go to the hospital
no let me give you the american example
when i go to the hospital i had
something wrong on my foot
three years ago they asked me you know
do you want to take
something do you want a pill i said no
five doctors and nurses ask me if i want
a pill
this is like worse than when you don't
accept water on the plane and they just
keep like do you want some more water
i'll take the water all right because i
don't want to be responsible for the
water like when the plane takes off and
it goes like this and i gotta like hold
it in my
i don't want no water like i don't
even know my like masseuse said i should
drink more water uh
so the so they
they there are like people they have
christmas parties about bonuses about
giving out more
medication so we talk about they do look
at this
how much does the earth cost exactly
there's no price on it right
we make money money's not even backed by
gold anymore so
it's engineering it's where the budgets
are going
and like it was the best part on uh one
of the best parts on the sixth sense
is when um
when they looked at this video and it
was a nanny
uh they saw that the nanny was like
putting stuff in like the porch for the
child that had passed
and he and then they said the ladies
looked at the nanny and said you were
keeping her sick
you're keeping her sick like we are sick
we are sick uh abortion culture
sex culture uh capitalism we are sick
we as a people as a not just the
american society of the world we are
sick and we are keeping ourselves sick
we're
all responsible like the black mirror
episode we're all responsible
in some way we all play some part like
if i go to
pornhub in the very next thing
um and i uh and like backslide and do
this because i struggle with this since
i was like five years old right
and the very next thing says something
about
like trafficking
then i literally would have to like put
my hand over that part
and like click the thing i'm going to
and thinking that like i'm not
a part of the the bigger conglomerate
that we're all
oh i'm not really a part of the main
problem because i'm i'm not as bad as
that guy and i'm not looking at this
part and i'm not like
we all play a part of it then we're all
sick in some way and the world has been
designed to keep
us sick like spatial
engineering based off faith
can save a world literally like building
will save the world spatial engineering
like
engineering not going to space
engineering our spaces the amount of
space that we need
the way that we interact with each other
how close we are to our loved ones
our families how close we are to our
jobs we got to experience a lot of this
some people
it wasn't good some people it's better
they were connected with their children
and their families in a whole different
way like we're talking
this is my thing we could talk about all
of these important
current issues there's
deeper reasons based on the slave
mentality based on fear
based on protectionism not specifically
white supremacy and racism
protectionism people just want to
protect what they have and there's this
like
photograph where you're holding um the
guys
the little girls holding a teddy bear
and jesus has a giant teddy bear
behind her um her back
i mean behind his back she don't want to
give up the small teddy bear
for the bigger teddy bear that jesus has
waiting for her
there is prosperity for all families
here on earth right now in service
to god there's happiness there's joy
it's not a possibility it's a
probability just the fact that god
woke me up got me here safely and
allowed me to talk to you
right now and spark the minds
of the people that are anointed to
change the world
is already what god wanted me to do if i
didn't take a breath
after this point god had me here for
this conversation
right now but i think god has more for
me playing i don't think they gonna come
for me until he done
until he done with me they ain't gonna
come for me until they done with me
i want to make it so if someone wanted
to sample and put in a beat it'd be like
perfect
[Laughter]
they ain't gonna come they ain't gonna
come for me until they done with me they
ain't gonna come for me until he done
with me
uh yeah yeah yeah help yourself you're
always creating
now yeah but do you understand what i'm
saying
okay tell me what i'm saying what you're
saying is that
it's it's your overall philosophy
the way you're approaching life you're
approaching life that there
is good for everyone if we
if we all work together if we all work
together in the spirit of the way you
think
the spirit of god that will
not not approach this like with a famine
mentality
but approach this like there's enough
for everybody there's an abundance if we
if we engineer it correctly
if we think about it correctly if we all
come together with the spirit of
everybody helping everybody this is the
spirit of christianity this is
the good spirit of christianity not the
christianity that gets despised or
disparaged or you know evangelists
driving around in private jets
the the spirit of of goodness and
treating each other like brothers and
sisters
yes but this can be done on a national
scale yes
because those evangelists or the people
who who spread the word of god
you know there's people who are praying
for me you know we're praying like i
said
i like to okay yes i
am a genius but one of my most genius
skill sets is recognizing other geniuses
and empowering them and giving them the
platform so the people that have been
praying for me this whole time
you know for jay to work for the kingdom
look at me
look at me right here working from the
kingdom that not leaning on my ego
not leaning on anything but leaning on
god in this situation saying
let's you know let's rise up together
and show people what it's like
to be christ like yeah we fall short you
know i mean
people love to like look at the
christians that are the least
christ-like to judge christianity
as a whole well a lot of people got
jordans in 23 years old and
don't very few of them play like lebron
you know they want to be like
like mike but there's very few people
that get that close
you know it's like yeah yeah what you're
saying is beautiful
yeah that they do judge the people that
fail
people always go to the furthest extent
like if you talk about uh abortion
culture
people immediately go to rape but don't
do
the math on what percentage that is and
for me as a
as a christian president
you know as i said i go on that i
touched on him before
i realize we're in an imperfect world
you know when i
talk to uh my fellow christians and we
talk about meat
we talk about guns we talk about in this
imperfect world
there's a transition between where we
are today
and where we're going does yeah does the
meat industry have a
great impact on uh
the ozone i from what i hear it does
and we have to transition one of the
things i wanted
it's a thought that came in and thank
you for allowing me to give you the
thoughts that are
coming into my head as opposed to trying
to put me on a grid because i'm off the
grid
period the way i think clearly i paint
in circles
you know i don't i don't paint inside of
the lines right
so i was thinking about i forget the
lady's name starts with a t
but she changed the meat industry
because she was hsp like highly
sensitive person that's uh
and put the uh the cows in a in round
bins
and uh that's what i'm doing when i say
spatial engineering that's what i'm
doing
with our spaces that i'm designing with
the farms
and uh with the school systems
the unlearned systems the what are the
things that you're going to need
you know in the future because 30 years
we don't we don't even know we think
probably the things that we're learning
in school right now won't even apply
to people when they're 30 years old that
are learning this stuff
you know age especially with technology
especially with technology and the
people who design the curriculums
way before technology yeah so
i mean i was in computer programming
when i was uh
uh eight years old and i used to
know how to program this how i got into
music in seventh grade i had a
amiga computer that had 4096 colors
that's why i got that one
uh and i would program the different
sprites and
uh draw out each of the characters and
animate them and i thought that was the
next frontier to like and because i
would do like animation books i wanted
to be a
animator and then i started doing the
the music they had a music program on do
the music for the video games
and then i found myself running home
from school all the way from 95th street
to 119th street
to go and just keep programming the
music so this is like third
age you know 12 13
you know programming video games and
that being the gateway into
programming music i got a longer story
about that but i know you want to ask me
some more serious stuff so um
ding okay this is a big one
the military um if you
really did become president when excuse
me when you do become president
you're going to have to deal with
hostile governments
hostile militaries
and dictators you know people
in another country that in other
countries that don't have a value of
human life
and throughout history we've had
immense problems because of that because
of military conflicts
how do you think you will approach that
i mean you will be the
commander-in-chief of the greatest army
the world has ever known
if you're in that position and we have
to deal with some sort of a
military action with china what if china
takes over taiwan
what if they invade taiwan
what if something happens with syria
what if something happens with
iran what if something happens with
russia
and you have to make decisions about
military action
have you thought about this
yes i would
i have to say again like covet i'm a
civilian
and people could have all their
perspectives that they could have of
what they would do
in that situation but i would have the
greatest professionals
on the planet the most skilled people
that have all the
experience that would present the
information and i would make
the most sound rational decisions
and i would follow god's
will in my approach
to
to dealing with these other countries to
dealing with these other leaders
there's there's something about you know
our president's personality and
the the leader of north korea's
personality where there's
there's a level of common respect and
and that's the reason why they were able
to talk and
we we the fear had been taken
off of us like people who are
uh god-fearing
self-made uh servants
of their people
these these other you know scary
dictators they feel like they're that
for their country and if they see
a president that they know is just
taking a check or part of a bigger
conglomerate now i don't want it like i
said i want to denounce
any of the uh uh candidates
then
it's it's very it's very transactional
it's um
and
i just said a prayer in this situation
this isn't
you said a prayer because of what what
what what
motivated you to say a prayer right
there
the seriousness the significance of this
subject yeah absolutely
we can we can't jump from jokes about
this to
you know joking about people's lives
right we have to
completely be still in this moment
allow god to guide our steps
and ask the right questions
with the highest ranking officials
possible
this isn't something that you just wing
or that you just come in
and say i did a bit of research i got
this like
political answer right that's gonna get
a rise out of people like this is this
is people's lives
this is you know this is a whole
different you know setting or or mood
than what this whole
uh interview has has been about
this is you know people are suffering
in the throughout all sides in
in in israel and in nigeria and haiti
we're we're suffering the police force
in in
in in chicago and the the people the
people who have been
harmed by police and the police like
this all is going to take
serious time like time is love it's
going to take that love and that time
and
moments of listening moments of
understanding moments like when my wife
goes and visits
people in prison and she hears their
stories
she says i understand i understand
why you're into in
why you're in that situation i would
have did the same thing in this
situation
and for us to go to foreign countries
and really
understand why that they're you know
that they're in these situations
or why the killing has gone for so long
or why the hate
has gone so long and why the pain just
keeps on
you know compounding and compacting
there's the empathy that i just have as
an artist
that it doesn't become a two plus two
equals four situation my dad was
actually
a a a psychology major
and a christian uh therapist
and this therapy we talk about therapy
period it's like
we need healing internationally not just
selfishly for america america is number
one
internationally we need healing
and
i would lead i would
i would lead with with love
dignity the responsibility to our
country
the coverage of our families of our
soldiers
and in full service to god and to the
american people
it's the there's a mode
that i would be in in that position like
when i was a producer and i was a really
young man
i was running around
hopping on trains or
you know hopping turn styles and stuff
and like stealing from
cars and i mean not stealing cars but
stealing clothes from stores and
um then i was
selling music and uh you know going and
buying
leather jackets and stuff then you know
dating a whole bunch of girls going on
tour
and then i had a family and
i had to adjust a lot of my mentality
and behavior to grow and be the man
that i needed to be then god called me
and i gave my life to christ
and god is helping me to be the
christian that i need to be
and when it's in god's will that i
become the leader
i will become the leader that i need to
be
so right now as i said i'm a civilian
but
my heart my mind and my spirit
is in a place where i feel i know that
i'm being
i'm being called to captain this ship
like when roosevelt went in america was
in shambles
when i when i'd say those things about
those numbers when i went to adidas when
i went to
gap like i'm the person
that you actually call when things are
not going so well
you know you have that the mob movies is
the guy that goes cleans up everything
and like puts everything
i'm i'm like the forensic where in the
same way how
you saw my mind touch on ten things at a
time
and then i had to say ten sentences at a
time if i could say them or maybe narrow
them down to seven
that's the way my mind takes you know
information
in and then it synthesizes it and it
comes out as a song or comes out as a
product
using that mentality as a leader
fearless god-fearing we
will heal we will show the world what
america should be
the dream you said all this [ __ ] all the
things that you've said
in the most non-politician way i've ever
heard anybody describe these things
i know you really mean these things this
is this is it's
resonating with me that you're being a
hundred percent honest
and natural and that's that's
what we're missing in politics today i
mean it's one of the things that made
people excited about trump
as at least he was an alternative to the
political talk
he was an alternative to politicians
speak where you know they're being
dishonest and disingenuous
but you just accept it you know they're
reading things that have been written by
speech writers but you just accept it
because it says
the things that you want to hear checks
the boxes that'll say okay you got my
vote
what you're saying though is what you
really feel and you really think and
you're not saying it like a politician
and that's what's going to resonate and
people going to be mad at me if you get
pregnant you become president
you made kanye west seem likeable
you turned him into the [ __ ]
president you
made him seem like a rational choice for
president this conversation
exposes a side of you that i don't think
anybody's ever seen before
and a long-form conversation where you
realize that you you are a visionary you
do you do have
these ideas are real you're not posing
it's not [ __ ]
this is who you are and your well
thought out response
particularly to the idea of military
conflict it's very impressive man
praise god i'm glad i did that prayer
brother
listen we're three hours into this let's
wrap this up on a beautiful high note
um so people can write you in if they
want to and
uh we have uh a we have a video on that
brian yeah except brian will play this
video
on on how they can write you in and uh
we'll wrap it up here
here it is how to write in kanye west on
your ballot now
for people that are watching this on
youtube you'll be able to watch this and
on uh
on spotify you'll be able to watch this
but if you're just listening
you just got to go down to the part
where it says or write in
uh it's pretty straightforward write in
candidates
um it'll show you where you can write it
in
this video will be available this video
is on youtube right
it's on his uh twitter it's on twitter
okay
write in kanye west on your ballot it's
gonna be very interesting to see what
happens with this
[Laughter]
i'm telling you man that was one of the
most interesting and
impressive uh answers to any question
because it was so obvious that you were
you were coming from the heart
and that's that's what we all need right
now we all need no [ __ ]
absolutely well thank you brother it was
uh an honor really
thank you pleasure i'm glad we finally
did it yeah awesome this won't be the
last time all right let's do it again
all right goodbye everybody
[Music]
you